Well, good day.
Good day.
Guess my age?
59.
59?
62.
What the hell?
No, but be real.
好吧，你好。你好。猜猜我几岁？59。59？62。搞什么鬼？不是，但说真的。
No, really.
Actually, what are you?
I'm 57.
I think you're 50.
You've always been a year younger, right?
Were you still?
Or did you pass me?
No, no.
真的没有。其实，你多少岁？我57岁。我觉得你50岁。你一直都比我小一岁，对吧？你还是吗？还是说你已经超过我了？不，不。
It looks like you, I think you passed me.
What?
Yeah.
Oh, God, this backfired so much.
Welcome to Smartless.
Hi, guys.
Oh, hi.
Where we're going?
看起来像你，我觉得你超过我了。什么？对啊。噢，天哪，这回搬起石头砸了自己的脚。欢迎来到《聪明无知》（Smartless）。大家好。哦，嗨。我们要去哪？
I'm just finishing up a text here and sending.
Okay.
Wonderful.
Oh, good, good, good.
Yeah, now I'm back with you.
It's not bad you could come today.
And, J.B., we're having a little bit of an earlier start today.
So I'm imagining your morning, because I know you bake in two hours.
我只是在回一条短信然后发出去。好的。太好了。哦，很好，很好，很好。对，现在我又和你在一起了。你今天能来挺不错的。而且，杰·布（J.B.），我们今天稍微早一点开始。所以我能想象你的早晨，因为我知道你提前两个小时烤培根。
Baseball season is on.
So you're active on the trade front.
You're managing your various leagues.
Well, I've fast-forwarded through the final six innings of last night's game.
Right.
You tape the games?
Every night.
Every one of them.
棒球赛季开始了。所以你在球员交易方面很活跃。你在管理你的各种联赛。好吧，我快进了昨晚比赛最后六局。对。你把比赛录下来？每天晚上。每一场。
I watch every single.
And he watches them at like 5 a.m.
Why don't you watch them live?
Well, I just don't get them done before I go to sleep.
And so I finish them up the next morning.
That's it helps me get out of bed.
I've got the rest of the game to watch.
That's a reason to wake up in the morning.
我每一场都看。他大概早上5点看。你为什么不看直播？嗯，因为我在睡觉前看不完。所以我第二天早上接着看完。就是这样，这帮我起床。我还有剩下的比赛要看。这是早上醒来的动力。
Okay, so let me ask you a question.
Do you fast forward in between each play?
Yeah.
I wait until at least one runner's on base.
Preferably I like to get somebody to get to second base before I go to...
I watch Wheel of Fortune the same way.
Not I'm kidding.
I'll fast forward through the picking of the letters
好吧，那我问你个问题。你在每个投球之间会快进吗？对。我等到至少有一个垒上有人。最好是能有人上到二垒，我再去……我看法网（Wheel of Fortune）也是这样。不开玩笑。我会快进选字母的环节
until they get the puzzle kind of pathway down.
Until it's something that you can figure out.
Yeah, exactly.
Sean, and does anybody ever get one, guess one so early
that you just, it surprises you so much that you,
like you have a mistake with the canned cheese?
Like, does it go all over your hand at that point?
Like, oh, shh.
直到他们把谜题的轮廓弄得差不多。直到它变成你能猜出来的东西。对，没错。肖恩，有没有人曾经这么早、这么快就猜出一个词，让你大吃一惊，以至于你把罐装喷雾起司都弄错了？就那种，喷得到处都是，像这样，哦，嘘。
Or do you ever, like, point it to your temple?
Like, if you're trying to kill yourself, you know,
and you just squeeze it all over the side of your face?
Like, what does it call cheese whiz?
Yeah, that's it.
Yeah, yeah.
So, J.B., so I know J.B. does a bacon.
So he bakes in the time.
或者你会不会，把它指向你的太阳穴？就像，如果你想自杀，你知道的，然后你把它挤在脸的两侧？那叫什么来着，起司酱（Cheese Whiz）？对，就是那个。对，对。所以，杰·布，我知道杰·布要烤培根。所以他在那个时间烤。
So bacon is Dodger game speed through, right?
And then as soon as it's over and not before, I then go to my scores, my points.
How many points I've accrued on my fantasy baseball.
Coffee, coffee is accompanying all of this.
Coffee's very first.
Very first.
I need to light the fuse.
Sure.
所以烤培根的速度要赶上道奇队的比赛，对吧？然后一结束，绝不能提前，我就去查看我的比分，我的积分。我在梦幻棒球里积攒了多少分。咖啡，咖啡伴随着这一切。咖啡是第一位的。绝对第一位。我需要点燃导火索。当然。
And it's a long fuse, so it needs time to burn down into the 9-9.
For the bomb.
You need to light the fuse with a fuse.
coffee. That's why I don't drink coffee
because I don't want to be dependent on it.
Well, it's not that bad to
depend on, you know? Like you got
而且这是一根长导火索，所以需要时间烧到9比9。为了那颗炸弹。为了那颗炸弹。你需要用咖啡点燃导火索。这就是为什么我不喝咖啡，因为我不想对它产生依赖。好吧，依赖它其实也没那么糟，你知道吗？就像你有了
a half hour TikTok
until the dynamite gets hit and then
off you go.
You know, because if you don't
have a fuse mechanism,
you could find yourself
leaving for your day and then you're out
in the middle of the community.
半小时的TikTok时间，直到炸药被引爆，然后你就可以出发了。你知道的，因为如果你没有导火索机制，你可能会发现自己出门去过一天，然后你走到了社区中间。
And you know what in the community.
You smell something burning.
And you know, you've got to get to a bunker.
For sure, I understand.
So, so.
And that's unfortunate.
All right, so we're back to baseball.
I check my scores.
你懂的，在社区里。你闻到有什么东西在燃烧。然后你知道的，你得找个掩体。当然，我明白。所以，所以。那太不幸了。好吧，我们回到棒球。我查我的比分。
Check your scores.
And then I start doing my loop around the internet.
And it's a pretty high-brow loop, you know, Will.
I'm not dicking around with gossip sites.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm seeing what's going on in the dumpster fire.
And actually, it's funny to say that.
So this morning I had that same thing where I went.
查你的比分。然后我开始在互联网上闲逛。那是个相当有品位的闲逛，你知道的，威利。我才不在八卦网站上瞎混呢。对。对，我在看垃圾堆里发生了什么。其实，说得挺有意思的。所以今天早上我也有同样的经历，我
woke up and I did, I did my little, my games with my little crew, coffee, obviously,
accompanying it.
And then...
Oh, right.
So, yeah, yeah.
So your, your baking...
I'm still in that old...
Yeah, so he's still doing...
醒来，然后我做了我的小游戏，和我的一小帮朋友，当然还有咖啡相伴。然后……哦，对。所以，对，对。所以你，你的烘焙……我还沉浸在那个旧的……对，所以他还在玩……
Whittal, quirtle, and octortle.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
So that takes you...
And the gum is as good as it sounds.
Sorry, just checking real quick.
So you're...
What, what...
Whittal、quirtle和octortle。对。嗯哼。所以这花去了你……这口香糖和听起来一样好吗。抱歉，我刚刚快速查一下。所以你……什么，什么……
How long does it take you usually to do those three things?
20 minutes.
It depends because the way we played is
the winner from the day before
picks the starter word that you have to use
for all three boards the next day.
They've really mixed it up.
So wait, what happens?
你通常花多长时间做这三件事？20分钟。这得看情况，因为我们玩的规则是前一天的赢家挑选一个起始单词，第二天所有人必须在所有三个面板上都使用这个词。他们真的把规则搞得很复杂。等等，怎么个玩法？
Yesterday's winner picks the starter word.
The starter word that you have to use
on all three boards the next day.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
So today's word was sadly.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, they always get you with an L-Y.
昨天的赢家挑选起始单词。第二天你必须在所有三个面板上使用的起始单词。哦，真的吗？对。所以今天的词是 sadly（悲伤地）。嗯哼。对，他们总是用带有 L-Y 的词来整你。
And certain people
like, we'll pick Dickey words
just to fuck you over
and it fucks themselves over too.
Sure.
And a dicky word would be something
that doesn't really provide a lot of vowels
or a lot of consonants.
而且有些人，我们会挑一些很难的词来恶心你，结果也把自己给恶心了。当然。所谓的难词就是那些不太能提供很多元音或辅音的词。
On Easter, our pal put in bunny.
Sure.
Okay, from the night before.
It's festive.
It's festive, but B-U and NY
is a desert when it comes to that game.
So it really messed us up.
So today, so I do that, get that wrapped up.
在复活节那天，我们的好朋友出了个 bunny（兔子）。当然。好吧，来自前一晚。很有节日气氛。很有节日气氛，但 B-U 和 N-Y 在那个游戏里简直就是一片沙漠。所以这真的把我们坑惨了。所以今天，我做完那个，把那个搞定。
And then...
How'd you do today?
You feel good about your sport?
No, I did.
I made a really...
Here we go, Sean.
This is why I don't plan anymore.
然后……你今天表现怎么样？你对自己的成绩满意吗？不，我做到了。我犯了一个真的……我犯了一个真的……来吧，肖恩。这就是为什么我不再做计划了。
Listen to this.
The word from yesterday was sadly.
And this morning, it was a word on our turtle.
So we all had a one.
Oh, really?
Which is rare, yeah.
And so, and then I was like, oh, I'm killing it.
听着这个。听着这个。昨天的词是 sadly。而今天早上，它成了我们的 octortle 里的一个词。所以我们都猜中了一个。哦，真的吗？这很罕见，对吧。然后，然后我就想，哦，我太牛了。
And I made one error on the third word in our turtle.
Good, Sean.
Get him.
What was your error, you fucking moron?
I don't even want to go into it.
I actually, this is what a loser am, I audibly went, no!
Because the letter was already not supposed to be there, and I did it.
I had like a brain.
结果我在 octortle 的第三个词上犯了一个错误。干得好，肖恩。抓住他。你犯了什么错，你这蠢货？我甚至不想提它。实际上，这就是我有多失败，我当场喊了出来：“不！”因为那个字母本来就不应该在那里的，而我还是放了。我脑子短路了。
It's incredible.
Anyway, but what I was going to get to is that I turned on the news.
I looked at some of the news online.
I did a little search around.
Same sort of thing.
And it was such a bummer.
And I thought to myself, and it's not the first time, I thought, why am I starting myself out in a rut?
I got a
真是难以置信。不管怎样，我要说的是我打开了新闻。我看了一些网上的新闻。我到处搜了搜。差不多也是这样。然后觉得太扫兴了。我心里想，这也不是第一次了，我想，我为什么一开头就要让自己陷入泥潭？我有了一个
now I got a rally to die at this point
I'm so low
because the news is
as we know
so much of it is so depressing
and so
and I thought
by the time I stopped looking at
现在我得振作起来去死，因为我现在情绪太低落了，因为新闻正如我们所知，很多都太压抑了，所以，而且我想等我看完
New York Times
Bloomberg Washington Post
all these I thought
what's the point
I guess so then what's the
alternative is
is maybe tweaking your algorithm
such that or not looking
《纽约时报》、《彭博社》、《华盛顿邮报》所有这些之后，我想，有什么意义呢？我想也是，那有什么替代方案呢？也许是调整你的算法，让它或者不去看
like yeah but what if you go to Instagram
and it's and you've managed to
get the algorithm pointed towards, you know,
unicorns and rainbows and stuff,
and you get uplifting messages and all that stuff.
Sure.
I think that that's positive, for sure.
But I think that actually what I came to today was,
就像，对啊，但如果你上 Instagram，然后你设法把算法引导到，你知道的，独角兽和彩虹之类的内容，然后你得到了振奋人心的信息和所有这些。当然。我认为那是积极的，肯定的。但我认为其实我今天得出的结论是，
I talked to Shawnee earlier after I got off the thing,
and I talked to him, we talked about stuff,
and that was good as a pallet cleanser.
And then I was like, you know what?
I think from now on I should play my game,
put my three games,
put the phone down,
and do some, go outside, like two days ago,
我之前跟肖尼聊过，在我忙完之后，我跟他谈了谈，我们聊了一些事情，这作为一个情绪缓冲挺好的。然后我就想，你知道吗？我觉得从现在开始，应该玩完游戏，把那三个游戏玩了，把手机放下，做点别的，去外面走走，就像前天一样，
because I still had jet lag.
I started my little walk that you've done with me before,
a little bit.
I started at 615.
This is with the ankle weights, wrist weights,
leg warmers, and the weighted vest.
Weighted vest.
And high elbows, right?
因为我还有时差。我开始了我的小散步，你以前陪我走过的那种，稍微走了一点。我6点15分开始。这是带着脚踝负重、手腕负重、腿套和负重背心。负重背心。还有高抬肘，对吧？
As you're going up the hills.
Weighted vest.
Fuck.
Weighted vest with a visor and spiky hair.
And you do one of the sort of a face shield,
one of those droopy masks to keep the sun off your skin?
No, I've got pharmacy, like Florida sunglasses.
You can put over your glasses full around.
当你上山的时候。负重背心。操。穿着负重背心，戴着遮阳帽和刺儿头假发。你还戴那种类似面罩的东西，就是那种为了防止阳光晒到皮肤上的下垂面罩？不，我有药房那种佛罗里达风格的太阳镜。你可以戴在你的眼镜外面，包围式的。
Okay?
I got Watman headphones.
Any sort of reflective material on your back so you don't get run over?
No.
Full sleeves.
Lots of waves.
Wait a minute.
好吧？我有渥特曼（Walkman）耳机。你背上有什么反光材料吗，这样你才不会被车撞？没有。全袖。全袖。不停地挥手。等一下。
Speaking of walking last...
Yeah.
But to wrap it up.
Please.
That's the way because I feel like it was starting...
But you try meditation?
Have you ever tried meditation?
I have.
说到上一次散步……对。但总而言之。拜托。这就是方法，因为我觉得它开始……但你试过冥想吗？你试过冥想吗？我试过。
I'd like to do...
I'd just shutting the fuck up.
Do you ever try that?
How about that?
Let's get to the guest.
Thank you, Sean.
What do you got for us today?
Wait, really quick.
我想做的是……就是他妈的闭嘴。你试过这个吗？这个怎么样？我们请嘉宾吧。谢谢你，肖恩.你今天给我们带来了什么？等等，等一下。
Did I go on too much?
No, you did.
Last night I was walking and I ran into, you know what a bollard is?
One of those cement stoppers at the end of a street or a sidewalk.
And it was like, oh, God, I ran.
You walked into it?
Yes.
Oh, you're talking about something that's about Nard height, right?
我是不是说得太多了？不，你确实说了。昨晚我在散步，然后撞上了，你知道什么是阻车桩（bollard）吗？就是街道或人行道尽头的那种水泥挡桩。当时我就想，天哪，我撞上了。你撞上它了？对。哦，你说的是大概到蛋蛋高度的东西，对吧？
Yes, exactly.
It's just a little higher than a fire hydrant.
And it was painted black.
Okay.
Why do they have them on the corner of a sidewalk?
So that people don't drive up.
Sounds like your Upper East Side.
It sounds very, I know those black.
对，没错。比消防栓稍微高一点。而且它是漆成黑色的。好吧。为什么人行道拐角会有那种东西？为了不让人开车上去。听起来很像你们上东区。听起来很，我知道那些黑色的。
No, no.
It's after I ate at the Waverly Inn restaurant.
Oh, no.
Oh.
So did you catch it right in the nards?
No, right above the knee.
And I couldn't.
Oh, man.
不，不。那是我在威弗利客栈（Waverly Inn）餐厅吃完饭之后。哦，不。哦。那你直接撞到蛋蛋上了吗？没有，就在膝盖上方。我简直……哦，天哪。
That got hurt.
Did you call Graydon Carter for a reservation?
Yeah.
You did?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, you did it?
No, no.
那可真疼。你给格雷登·卡特（Graydon Carter）打电话订位了吗？对。你打了？对。不，不，不，不。哦，你打了？不，不。
Did Scotty throw you over his shoulder and walk you home?
Basically.
It was right in front of a taxi and we were saying goodbye,
and I was like, I ran right into the thing with my full leg.
And I was just like, did we run?
Great time.
No.
I just walked right into it.
斯科蒂（Scotty）把你扛在肩上送你回家了吗？差不多吧。就在一辆出租车前面，我们正在道别，然后我就……我整条腿直接撞到了那个东西上。然后我就像，我们跑了吗？好时光。没有。我直接撞上去了。
Yeah.
No.
All right, let's get to it.
Ready?
What's your step count a day?
I'm guessing, 400?
Sorry.
My guest today accidentally taught his two-year-old son to say, I'm a coward, which made me laugh
对。不。好吧，我们开始吧。准备好了吗？你一天的步数是多少？我猜，400步？抱歉。我今天的嘉宾不小心教他两岁儿子说：“我是个懦夫，”这让我笑了
when I read that.
He went to Georgetown and majored in history.
His father's job included tracking the hidden fortunes of dictators.
after bombing at his first college comedy competition,
the guy that won invited him to audition for a sketch show,
and that changed the course of his life.
He's voiced about 80 animated characters, for real,
and the kid he met on the first day of first grade
当我读到的时候。他毕业于乔治敦大学，主修历史。他父亲的工作包括追踪独裁者隐藏的财富。在大学第一场喜剧比赛中砸场后，赢得比赛的那个人邀请他去试镜一个素描喜剧秀，这改变了他的人生轨迹。他为大约80个动画角色配音，真的，他在一年级第一天遇到的小孩
became his best friend and creative partner,
helping turn their own humiliating stories about puberty
into one of Netflix's longest-running scripted originals.
It's the insanely funny and super-talented Nick Kroll.
Oh, Nick!
Nicholas Kroll!
Get out here!
Hey, boys.
成为了他的最好朋友和创意伙伴，帮他们把自己关于青春期的耻辱经历变成Netflix上播放时间最长的剧本原创剧之一。他就是疯狂搞笑且超级有才华的尼克·克罗尔（Nick Kroll）。哦，尼克！尼克拉斯·克罗尔！快出来吧！嗨，伙计们。
Oh, he's going to take it down.
I have not spoken yet today, and I'm listening to my voice.
That was like the first thing I've said all day.
Wouldn't it be amazing if we all, wouldn't it be amazing if we all had a word limit each day?
Like every person.
For you, it would be, yeah.
Hey.
But could you imagine if you had to budget out your words for the day?
哦，他要把这个关掉。我今天还没说过话，我在听我自己的声音。那就像我今天一整天说的第一句话。如果大家都有每天的字数限制，那不是很惊艳吗？就像每个人都一样。对你来说，那会是，对。嘿。但你能想象如果你必须为一天预算你的字数吗？
That would be pretty interesting.
That would be cool.
Well, man.
Boy, you come up with some fun ideas.
Nick.
You are East Coast because you've already got a smart-looking jacket on.
I'm on the West Coast.
I was debating on taking the jacket off before,
那会相当有趣。那会很酷。好吧，老兄。天哪，你能想出一些有趣的主意。尼克。你是东海岸的，因为你已经穿了一件看起来很时髦的夹克。我在西海岸。我刚才还在纠结要不要把夹克脱掉，
but I'm dealing with what you guys are seeing is this center stage video
where I'm going to be constantly, the camera's going to be following me.
You can turn that off.
You can't turn it off if you will.
I know I can.
I can't figure out how.
Wait, why do you look so damn good already this one?
You got a chore jacket on?
但我正在应付你们大家看到的这个中心舞台视频，我得不断地，摄像头会一直跟着我。你可以把它关掉。如果你愿意的话，你是关不掉的。我知道我可以。我不知道怎么弄。等等，为什么你现在看起来这么帅？你穿着一件工装夹克？
You got a callback earlier?
I got, yeah, it's a Lipton Cup of Soup.
It's a 3 p.m. slump.
and did you crush it?
I felt good.
I felt really good in the room.
Any feedback yet?
Yeah, supposedly they wanted
你刚才接到回电了？我接到，对，是立顿杯汤（Lipton Cup of Soup）的广告。那是下午3点的疲惫时刻。你搞定了吗？我觉得很好。我在房间里的感觉真的很好。有反馈了吗？对，据说他们想要
better looking and older, though.
Oh, wow.
You are in the running
in case they can't find that.
Yeah, so you guys are honestly
out of this.
We're the demo.
We're that.
长得更好看、年纪更大的人。哦，哇。如果他们找不到那样的人，你就在候选名单里。对，所以老实说你们俩出局了。我们就是那个样板。我们就是那种。
Telsey's calling, guys.
Nick Kroll,
what's up, man?
It's been a long time.
How are you?
I'm great.
it's really good to see you guys.
Likewise.
泰尔西（Telsey）在打电话了，伙计们。尼克·克罗尔，怎么了，老兄？好久不见。你好吗？我很好。很高兴见到你们。彼此彼此。
It's just to see you.
Nick, the first time I met you was, I think,
was at Ted Serendez's as a couple years ago
at the Grammy dinner thing.
Yes.
Right?
What were you two doing at a Grammy?
At the Grammy?
很高兴见到你。尼克，我第一次见你，我想是在特德·萨兰多斯（Ted Sarandos）家里，几年前的格莱美晚宴上。是的。对吧？你们俩在格莱美晚宴上干什么？在格莱美？
Yeah.
It was like, for the comedy category.
And we were doing a duet.
It was a Bet Midler and Barry Mantelow thing.
And they had us play for a few minutes.
Right, right.
No, but I, you were so kind.
And I immediately felt this, like,
对。就像是为了喜剧类奖项。我们在表演一个对唱。那是贝特·米德勒（Bette Midler）和巴里·曼尼洛（Barry Manilow）的节目。他们让我们演了几分钟。对，对。不，不过我，你太友善了。我立刻感受到了一种，像
rhythm with you.
And I was like, oh, I'd love to get to nervous.
Thank you.
Here we go.
This is unbelievable.
Every time I felt a connection with you.
Let me put your number in the chat.
Are you joking?
和你之间的默契。然后我就想，哦，我很想变得紧张。谢谢你。来吧。这太不可思议了。每次我都对你产生了一种连接感。让我把你的号码发在聊天里。你在开玩笑吗？
Come on the pod.
You should come on the podcast sometimes.
Let's go from lunch and wrap up
how we think we did.
I'm close by.
What's your story later?
Because you should come on the pod.
The boys let me make the choices on this all the time.
上播客来。你有时应该来上这个播客。我们去吃个午饭，总结一下我们觉得自己表现得怎么样。我就住在附近。你稍后有什么安排？因为你真该上这个播客。伙计们总是让我来做这些选择。
Connie is so.
You're so smart and funny and handsome and...
Let's go on a run.
You want to go for a run?
Wait, let's go on a run.
Wait, wait.
So that was the first time that you guys had met?
康妮太……你是那么聪明、有趣、英俊，而且……我们去跑步吧。你想去跑步吗？我们去跑步吧。等等，我们去跑步吧。等等，等等？所以那是你们第一次见面？
I actually met you many, many, many years earlier.
There was a guy used to do, like, treasure hunts around L.A.
Oh, yes.
A J.P. Manu.
Yes.
Are you talking about the LARF?
I don't know if that's what it was.
No, it was before Amazing Rew.
其实我很多很多很多年前就见过你了。以前有个家伙在洛杉矶到处搞寻宝游戏。哦，是的。J.P.马努（J.P. Manu）。是的。你在说 LARF 吗？我不知道那是不是叫这个。不，那是《惊险大挑战》（Amazing Race）之前的事。
I remember that thing.
And it was just like the amazing race.
And this guy organized just a bunch of people
to go do this around Los Angeles.
It was really fun.
Yeah, so you were there, and you, like,
I was just sort of starting,
and you were one of the most famous people in the world.
我记得那个。就像《惊险大挑战》一样。这家伙组织了一群人在洛杉矶周围玩这个。真的很有趣。对，所以你在那儿，然后你，就像，我当时刚出道，而你是世界上最有名的人之一。
In that group of five.
And so I saw you, and I said,
one day, they're going to make podcasts,
and I'm going to hit on him at Ted Sorrento's party.
Wait a second.
You're skipping over the day.
that you predicted podcasts.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
在那五个人里。所以我看到你，我说，总有一天，他们会做播客，我要在特德·萨兰多斯的派对上向他搭讪。等一下。你跳过了你预测播客的那天。对，对，对，对。
Why, that's just...
We had to get to Madam Tussos to find...
That's right.
That's true.
Why have those gone...
Wait, so...
J.B., do you remember in the 90s,
为什么，那只是……我们得去杜莎夫人蜡像馆找到……没错了。确实如此。确实如此。为什么那些都不见了……等等，所以……杰·布，你还记得在90年代，
these guys had a game going for a while?
It was called LARF, and they were both out of Stanford.
There was one...
No, there was another one where we went around,
and everybody had a squirt gun,
and it was like a game of tag around L.A.
I did that as a kid. I did that as a kid.
My daughter does that as senior...
这些家伙曾经搞过一个游戏吗？叫作 LARF，他们俩都是斯坦福毕业的。还有一个……不，还有另一个是我们四处跑，每个人都有一把水枪，就像在洛杉矶玩捉人游戏一样。我小时候玩过那个。我小时候玩过那个。我女儿在读高三时也玩那个……
No, but all these actors, when we were in our...
20s in the 90s in LA.
I remember being out here for pilot season, mid-90s,
and somebody's saying, do you want to get in this thing?
And people would be, like, at an audition at Warner Brothers,
and some dude would come out of nowhere and spray him and, like,
you're going to be like, you're in?
And I was like, can you imagine walking onto a lot now with a water gun?
不，但是所有这些演员，当我们在……90年代20多岁在洛杉矶的时候。我记得在90年代中期试镜季来这里，有人说，你想加入这个吗？人们会，比如在华纳兄弟公司试镜，然后有个家伙突然冒出来朝他喷水，然后就像，你要加入吗？然后我想象不出来现在带着水枪走进片场会是什么样。
So at Franny School, so it's senior assassin,
if you get hit with a water gun, you're out.
And the only way that you can sort of protect yourself,
inoculate yourself from getting some sort of a surprise hit
is wearing swim goggles out in public,
all day, every day, or swim floaties.
So you see like these students are all around town,
you know, like markets and shopping,
所以在弗兰尼学校（Franny School），那是毕业班刺客游戏，如果你被水枪击中，你就出局了。唯一能让你保护自己、免受某种突然袭击的方法就是在大庭广众之下整天、每天都戴着游泳护目镜，或者戴着游泳臂圈。所以你会看到这些学生在全城到处都是，你知道的，比如市场上和购物时，
and they're really funny.
It's pretty cool.
But these scavenger hunts things,
these high-end scavenger hunts,
I'm pissed that they've gone away.
We should resurrect that.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
他们真的很有趣。挺酷的。但是这些寻宝游戏，这些高端的寻宝游戏，我真的很气它们消失了。我们应该把它复活。我们干吧。对。
Celebrity scavenger hunt.
Let's do it, guys.
You guys have a lot of free time.
Do you want to start getting into it?
Let's do
organizing
local city scavenger hunts
I'm going to organize
名人寻宝游戏。我们干吧，伙计们。你们有很多空闲时间。你们想开始参与吗？让我们开始组织当地城市的寻宝游戏吧，我要组织
Nick Kroll
Let's get into it
You first of all
Thanks for being here
And I did
I did mean that
I just felt like a comedy
connection with you
尼克·克罗尔。我们开始吧。首先，谢谢你能来。我是认真的，我觉得我和你有一种喜剧上的默契。
You were very funny
Right off the bat
And I felt like I've known you
But anyway
He's a nice guy
And he's funny
He's a very nice guy
What's not to get a rhythm with
你非常有趣，一上手就很搞笑。而且我觉得我好像认识你很久了。总之，他是个好人。而且他很有趣。他是个非常好的人。怎么能不产生默契呢
So wait
Is that true 80 voices
80 80 80 80?
I think that's what I think so
And is like if I
threw out names, you don't want to do that.
I probably could. I mean, I'm a monkey.
I'll give you what you need. Let's get those numbers, folks.
所以等等，那是真的吗？80个声音，80，80，80，80？我想是这样的。如果我抛出名字，你不想那样做的话。我大概可以。我是个猴子。你要什么我都给你。把那些数字拿出来，伙计们。
I'm going to do a fat, look here.
Gunter from Singh and Sing too.
Ah yeah, this is Gunter from Singh.
It's major PG power.
Okay.
Nothing makes me laugh quicker than a German accent.
What about douche from sausage party?
我要来个胖的，看这里。《欢乐好声音》（Sing）和《欢乐好声音2》里的冈瑟（Gunter）。啊，是的，这是《欢乐好声音》里的冈瑟。这很有 PG 级的威力。好吧。没有什么比德国口音更能让我更快发笑了。好吧。那《香肠派对》（Sausage Party）里的 douche 呢？
Dush was
Oh, come at me, bro.
It was that sort of
that guy.
No, but wait, no, but wait, do douche from sausage parties.
Okay, so wait.
So, Dush from Sausage Party, we did,
that's the Rogan movie,
Douche 是……哦，来啊，兄弟。就是那种类型的家伙。不，但是等等，不，但是等等，来一段《香肠派对》里的 Douche。好吧，所以等等。所以，《香肠派对》里的 Douche，我们做了，那是罗根（Rogan）的电影，
and I did the whole thing as like a
sort of a British villain,
like a, you know, the classic Disney British,
like Jafar kind of voice,
and then, or like a scar from Lion
And it just wasn't working, and we did one last record
where they rewrote it as that character.
This character did Bobby Bottle Service, who was kind of, yeah.
我整段都用那种英国反派的声音来演，就像，你知道的，经典迪士尼式的英国反派，像贾方（Jafar）那种声音，或者像《狮子王》里的刀疤。就是行不通，然后我们进行了最后一次录音，他们把剧本重写成了那个角色。这个角色做过鲍比瓶装服务（Bobby Bottle Service），也是那种，对。
I remember Bobby Bottle Service.
Wait, Nick, you did your series on Netflix.
Big Mouth?
Big Mouth.
Yeah.
So we got to clear the air on this.
Do you know what I'm getting in?
Of course.
我记得鲍比瓶装服务。等等，尼克，你在 Netflix 上做过你的系列剧。大嘴（Big Mouth）？《大嘴》。对。所以我们得把这事说清楚。你知道我要说什么吗？当然。
So we've never talked about it.
So for years, people have commented me,
hit me in the thing, talked to you,
to me in real life, I've been in line at the store.
Do you do the voice of, there's a character on your show
that people thought was me?
His name is Mori, the hormone monster.
当然。所以我们从没谈过这个。多年来，人们一直在评论我，在现实生活中对我说，我在商店排队时，有人问我：你是不是那个角色的配音？你节目里有个角色，人们以为是我？他的名字叫莫里（Mori），荷尔蒙怪物。
Is that what it is?
Everybody thinks it's Arnett.
Yeah.
It's, it's, I can't tell you how many people have...
And that's you, Nick?
It's me.
Are you, Nick Dilling Arnette?
No, it's, I mean, this is, okay, so here's a backstory here.
是这样的吗？每个人都以为是阿奈特（Arnett）。对，对。是这样的，我无法告诉你有多少人……那是你吗，尼克？是我。你，尼克·迪林·阿奈特（Nick Dilling Arnett）？不，我是说，这是一个，好吧，这里有个幕后故事。
Let's clear the air on this.
Let's clear it finally.
Finally.
So I, we did the show Big Mouth.
It's about kids going through puberty.
And my friend Andrew Goldberg, who Sean mentioned, I met in first grade.
We created the show together.
He had been at Family Guys for years.
我们把这事说清楚吧。终于说清楚了。终于。所以，我们做了《大嘴》这个节目。讲的是孩子们经历青春期。我的朋友安德鲁·戈德堡（Andrew Goldberg），就是肖恩提到的那个，我一年级认识的。我们一起创作了这个节目。他在《恶搞之家》（Family Guy）工作多年。
We've been friends forever.
And he and Mark and Jen, our other partners, came to me with an idea about an animated show about kids, about me and Andrew at 13 going through puberty.
Yeah.
And immediately it was like, great.
This makes, I really see this show.
started working on it and Andrew started talking about
he's like you know and like
I think my guy who he was a really
我们一直是永远的朋友。他和我们的另一个合伙人马克和詹找到我，带给我一个关于动画节目的创意，关于孩子们，关于我和安德鲁在13岁经历青春期。对。然后立刻就觉得，太棒了。这很有道理，我真的能看到这个节目。开始制作，安德鲁开始说，他说，你知道的，就像我觉得我的那个家伙，他是个很
early early developer
you know he just hit puberty at like
five and had a full beard by
eight you know and he was
and he was sort of like I think my character
was like with something encourages him
to jerk off like he's got like
a hormone monster
早熟的开发者，你知道的，他大概5岁就经历了青春期，8岁就留了满脸大胡子，你知道的，他当时，而且他有点像，我觉得我的角色就像是有某种东西鼓励他手淫，他就像有一个荷尔蒙怪物。
and I immediately was literally
immediately it was like
touch yourself Andrew
and it was like that was the voice
Because I'd been doing this guy
I'd been doing this guy Nash Riki
I had a sketch show called Kroll Show
Nash Ricky was sort of like a hair metal guy
我立刻，真的可以说是立刻就说：“抚摸你自己，安德鲁，”然后就有了那个声音。因为我一直在扮演这个家伙，我一直在扮演纳什·瑞奇（Nash Riki），我以前有个素描喜剧秀叫《克罗尔秀》（Kroll Show），纳什·瑞奇有点像那种重金属摇滚乐手，
who was also like had OCD
Yeah yeah yeah
Wait did was Pete Giles part of that
Yes Pete Giles was part of that yeah
Yeah we had a we had a song called L.A. Delhi
And it was just about all the delis in L.A.
Like California girls
Because all those guys like hung out of
同时也有强迫症。对，对，对。等等，皮特·吉尔斯（Pete Giles）是其中的一部分吗？是的，皮特·吉尔斯是其中的一部分，对。我们有一首歌叫《洛杉矶熟食店》（L.A. Deli）。这首歌就是关于洛杉矶所有的熟食店。就像加州女孩一样。因为所有那些家伙都喜欢在
You know fucking cantors and all
Yeah anyway so I did this voice
Snash, Ricky.
So then we go to do Big Mouth, we develop it, we make it, it comes out.
I've known Will forever.
Will is on the air with Bojack at this, like, so...
The same time, Bojack is like the premier fucking animated show.
It never crossed my mind that anyone would be like, is that Arnette?
你知道的，该死的坎特（Canter's）之类的鬼地方闲逛。不管怎样，我做了这个声音，纳什·瑞奇。然后我们去拍《大嘴》，我们开发它，制作它，它上映了。我认识威利很久了。威利当时正在播音，跟《马男波杰克》（Bojack）一起，所以……与此同时，《马男波杰克》是首屈一指的该死的动画片。我从来没想过会有人问，那是阿奈特吗？
And then we start the show, and it works, and everybody's like,
Can't believe you got Arnette.
You sound like Arnette.
Nick, Nick, honestly, I can't tell you how many people over the years.
I'm like, no, it's not, I think it's, I didn't know if it was you, but I was like,
I think it's cruel.
Yeah.
Is that show still going?
然后我们节目开播了，反响很好，每个人都说：“真不敢相信你们请到了阿奈特。你听起来就像阿奈特。”尼克，尼克，说实话，这些年来我无法告诉你有多少人。我说，不，不是，我想那是，我不知道是不是你，但我觉得是克罗尔。对。那个节目还在播吗？
No, we did eight, we did eight seasons.
Wow, that's remarkable.
Yeah, that's a lot of it.
Yeah, we'll have done, we did more of those than basically any other scripted Netflix show, I think besides Ozark.
How many have you guys done 140?
It just felt like 140.
No, it was four and a half maybe seasons.
Yeah.
没有，我们拍了八季。哇，真了不起。对，那是很多季。对，我们拍的季数基本上比 Netflix 任何其他的剧本原创剧都要多，我大概觉得除了《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）之外。你们拍了多少集，140集？感觉就像140集。不，大概是四季半吧。对。
It's too, anyway, so we did it and we're about to put out a new show
called mating season.
It's the same team who made Big Mountain.
What's a premiere on that, Sean?
What's a premiere date host?
Oh, God, you, wait, I need to look it up.
I jumped it.
I got it.
总之，我们做完了，我们即将推出一部新剧叫《交配季节》（Mating Season）。制作《大嘴》的原班人马。首播是什么时候，肖恩？主持人，首播日期是什么时候？哦，天哪，你，等等，我得查一下。我抢先了。我查到了。
I had to scroll tighten this up later.
scrolling, scrolling.
When is it, Nick?
Guys, I'm so sorry.
Check the chat.
Maybe Michael Granteria sent it to you.
Oh, my God.
我查到了。我得晚点把这个精简一下。滚动，滚动。什么时候播，尼克？伙计们，实在对不起。查查聊天记录。也许迈克·格兰特里亚（Michael Granteria）发给你了。哦，天哪。
I can tell you.
I don't even know.
Double back at the end, Sean.
Okay.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Carl, so I know you, so I feel like the first time I saw you was at UCB over 20 years ago.
I think the first time we met you were maybe doing monologues at ASCat one night.
我可以告诉你。我甚至都不知道。肖恩，最后再倒回来查。好的。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。克罗尔，我知道你，所以我觉得我第一次见到你是在20多年前的 UCB（ Upright Citizens Brigade）。我想我们第一次见面时，你可能某天晚上在 ASCat 表演独白。
Yes, I think that would make sense.
Like early 2000s.
Yeah.
And you were so funny.
It was one of those, like the first time I saw you was like, oh, this dude is fucking hilarious.
Thank you.
Like right out of the gate.
So.
是的，我想这说得通。大概是2000年代初。对。而且你太搞笑了。那是那种，我第一次见你的时候就觉得，哦，这家伙太他妈搞笑了。谢谢。一出道就这么觉得。所以。
And then you just went on to do, what I love is that you went on,
and you and Malaney did so much cool stuff.
You did a show on Broadway.
You did, you did sketches, you did sketch shows.
You've just done, what I love is how many different kinds of things you have done.
You do stand-up, you do all of it.
And is there, is there, do you, now at this point do you go like,
oh, it feels too spread out, I want to concentrate on this,
然后你接着去做了，我最喜欢的是你继续前行，你和马拉尼（Mulaney）一起做了那么多酷炫的事情。你在百老汇演过剧。你演过，你演过素描，你做过素描秀。你只是做过，我最喜欢的是你做过多少种不同类型的事情。你做单口喜剧，你什么都做。而且有没有，有没有，你现在这个时候会想，哦，感觉摊子铺得太开了，我想专注于这个，
because I know you just did a stand-up special.
Yeah.
I just watched it.
It's so good.
Is that kind of where you want to go,
or do you feel like you still want to just do millions of different things?
I mean, what I'm shooting for is like a B-minus across the board.
You can shoot for a B-minus.
因为我知道你刚做了一个单口喜剧专场。对。我刚看过。太棒了。那是你想走的方向吗，还是你觉得你仍然只想做成千上万种不同的事情？我的意思是，我的目标是全面达到 B 减水平。你可以追求 B 减水平。
You can do so much.
You never disappoint yourself.
You can really, you don't shoot too high.
You stay general and broad,
and then nobody can attack you for fully committing to anything.
That's such a great call.
Oh, I know that.
Yeah.
你可以做很多事情。你永远不会让自己失望。你不会把目标定得太高。你保持通用和大众化，然后没有人能因为你全身心投入某件事而攻击你。这真是个绝佳的选择。哦，我知道那点。对。
Oh, yeah.
It's all about longevity.
It's all about just staying right in the middle
for as long as possible
and then they can't, don't get too tall.
Wait, the three of us, J.B., you, me, and Kroll
did that animated show with Mitch Hurwitz.
Yes.
哦，是的。这一切都是为了长盛不衰。这一切都是为了尽可能长时间地保持在中间位置，然后他们就无法，别把自己搞得太显眼。等等，我们三个，杰·布，你，我和克罗尔跟米奇·赫维茨（Mitch Hurwitz）一起做过那个动画节目。是的。
Sit down, shut up.
That was very, yeah, that was,
it was literally right after arrested.
And it was us and Forte.
Forte.
Damn, I want to watch that again.
I remember the animation being hilarious.
坐下，闭嘴（Sit Down, Shut Up）。《坐下，闭嘴》。那是真的，对，那是， буквально（字面意思）就在《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）之后。那是我们和福特（Forte）。福特。妈的，我想再看一遍。我记得那个动画搞笑极了。
What a cast that had.
Yeah, I'm playing a character I would not currently.
play, I don't think.
Copy that.
Oh, let's, please explain.
His name was
Andrew Legustambos,
那阵容太豪华了。对，我演了一个我目前可能不会再演的角色，我觉得。收到。收到。哦，请，请解释一下。他的名字叫安德鲁·莱古斯塔博斯（Andrew LeGustambos），
and it was a
Legosambos.
He liked,
he was a bisexual
Latin teacher.
Yeah.
Do you think,
I love that you remember his name?
他是莱古斯塔博斯。他喜欢，他是一个双性恋拉丁语老师。对。你觉得，我很喜欢你还记得他的名字？
No, but literally,
if you started that today,
do you think that
today's culture
would attack as much as it did,
let's say even six months to a year ago?
No, I think everything is,
I feel like things are kind of settling.
不，但说实话，如果你今天启动这个项目，你觉得今天的文化会像比如六个月到一年前那样猛烈抨击它吗？不，我觉得一切都在，我觉得事情正在某种程度上安定下来。
I mean, I don't think I would play that character right now,
but I do think things are settling a bit.
Like all of that stuff,
that I think we're finding different levels now to it, you know?
Right, right.
Yeah, I think so too.
And I wonder why.
I mean, the issues haven't gone away,
我的意思是，我觉得我现在不会演那个角色了，但我确实觉得事情正在慢慢安定下来。就像所有那些事情，我觉得我们现在对它找到了不同的层面，你知道的？对，对。对，我也这么觉得。我在想为什么。我的意思是，问题并没有消失，
but maybe the tolerance and the exploration of finding humor
in things that are more challenging
is more around?
I don't know.
I think there's a general...
I mean, I think there's polarizing views of it,
but I think there's a general attempt
to be more thoughtful
但也许对在更有挑战性的事物中寻找幽默的宽容度和探索更多了？我不知道。我觉得有一个普遍的……我的意思是，我觉得对此有两极分化的观点，但我认为普遍存在一种尝试，那就是对我们正在做的事情或我们做事的方式更加深思熟虑。
about what we're doing or how we're doing it.
And if you're generally more thoughtful,
then I think there's more,
a little more room for different versions of people
playing different versions of people.
I think, in that way, you know?
I think also there's...
Interesting.
如果你总体上更加深思熟虑，那么我认为就会有更多，有一点更多空间让不同版本的人去扮演不同版本的人。我想，在那种方式上，你知道的？我也觉得……有趣。
We have to pay more attention to...
intent, you know?
And if the intent is to injure or to sideline or to be hurtful,
then there's no room for it.
Let's save that for our personal friendships, right?
Yeah, of course.
And family, and family.
Exactly.
我们需要更多地关注动机，你知道的？如果动机是伤害、边缘化或具有攻击性，那么就没有它的容身之地。让我们把这留给我们的个人友谊吧，好吗？对，当然。还有家庭，还有家庭。没错。
Let's leave family out of this.
Wait, so Nick, when you first started out and mentioned in the intro,
you bombed freshman in comedy competition.
And the guy who won and then gave you the opportunity was Mike Barbiglia, right?
Yes.
That's crazy.
I mean, that's crazy.
Where was this?
我们别把家庭扯进来了。等等，尼克，当你刚出道时，正如开场所说，你在大学一年级喜剧比赛中砸场了。而赢得比赛并给你机会的人是迈克·巴比利亚（Mike Birbiglia），对吧？是的。这太疯狂了。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。这是在哪？
It was at Georgetown.
We did this thing called The Funniest Act on Campus.
And I'd never done comedy before in any real capacity.
And there were, you know, it's like flyers up.
And I went and did it.
I was really nervous about it.
And I just showed up and my whole bit was that I was going to get on stage and go, you know,
I thought I'd be so nervous, but I'm super relaxed.
在乔治敦大学。我们参加了一个叫作“校园里最搞笑的表演”（The Funniest Act on Campus）的活动。我以前从没真正意义上表演过喜剧。到处都是，你知道的，到处贴着传单。我就去参加了。我对此真的很紧张。我刚到那儿，我的整个段子就是我要上台说：“你知道，我以为我会很紧张，但我超级放松。”
And then I was going to piss my pants like that.
That's a great.
It's a good bit, right?
It's a really good bit.
Except I did not prepare.
I was like, you know, as a freshman college.
You didn't drink enough water? Yeah, I was like, had drank and like, you know, I was just
like so nervous that I showed up and I had not, I had not, I was going to bring like a water
然后我就要像那样尿裤子。那太棒了。这是个好段子，对吧？这真的是个好段子。除了我没有做准备。我就像，你知道的，作为一个大学一年级新生。你没有喝足够的水？对，我当时就像，喝了水，而且，你知道，我太紧张了以至于我去了，而且我没有，我没有，我本打算带一个水
balloon and a pen and like pop the water.
You know what I mean?
I thought, I didn't.
So, but I forgot all of it.
So I grabbed like a empty, a sandwich bag in the trash and grabbed a pen and just got on stage and
just like jammed
over and over
the pen into this like water bag in my pocket
气球和一个钢笔，然后把水扎破。你知道我的意思吗？我想，我没有。所以，但我把所有的东西都忘了。所以我从垃圾桶里抓了一个空的，三明治袋，拿了一支笔，然后上了台，只是不停地把笔戳进我口袋里的这个水袋里，
so it just looked like I was
jerking off on stage basically
which is what I've been doing ever since
but Mike
Mike won
Mike had like a solid five minutes
as like a sophomore and he won the
competition and got
所以看起来我基本上是在台上自慰，这也是我自那以后一直在做的事情，不过迈克赢了，迈克作为一个大二学生有一个稳定的五分钟表演，他赢得了比赛，并获得了
to start hosting at the DC Improv
and then he was doing a
sketch show later that year and invited me to audition
and I did that audition
and then got cast and we went to like a kid's
apartment on campus and read all these sketches.
And I like, it was truly the one time of my life, I walked out of that thing.
I was like, this is it.
在华盛顿即兴剧场（DC Improv）开始主持的机会，然后他在那年晚些时候做了一个素描喜剧秀，并邀请我去试镜，我参加了试镜并被选中，我们去了校园里一个小孩的公寓里朗读所有这些素描。我当时就觉得，这真是我生平仅有的一次，我走出那个地方时想：就是这个了。
Yeah.
This is all, this is it.
This is what I want to do.
Because what were you studying at Georgetown at the time?
I was studying history and minoring in art in Spanish, just kind of like coasting,
coasting on privilege.
That was getting goose you?
Yeah.
是的。就是这样，全都是为了这个。这就是我想做的事。因为你当时在乔治城大学学什么？我当时学的是历史，辅修艺术和西班牙语，有点像是混日子，靠着特权混日子。那是……真的吗？
Waiting for something to hit you to do?
Or were you going to make a career out of?
history. I was going to, I don't know. I think I was just, I truly was coasting. You know, I just was like,
I liked history because I think I liked telling stories. But I think I was still scared to like write.
And, you know, so English wasn't, didn't feel entirely safe. And then we started doing, and so we
auditioned for that sketch show. And we literally then went at the, we did our sketch. It was like,
we rehearsed for three months to do one night in Bulldog Alley on campus. And then, and the show was, I mean, we
bomb, but I met all these guys who I continue to know and work with still, including
在等什么灵感降临吗？还是你本来打算把历史当作……职业？我打算，我不知道。我觉得我当时就是，真的在混日子。你知道，我只是觉得我喜欢历史，因为我觉得我喜欢讲故事。但我觉得我当时还是不敢写作。所以，你知道的，英语专业让人感觉没那么安全。然后我们开始做，于是我们去为那个小品秀试镜。然后我们真的就去了，我们排练了三个月，只为了在校园里的布杂小巷（Bulldog Alley）演一个晚上。然后，演出嘛，我的意思是，我们演砸了，但我遇到了所有这些我至今仍保持联系并一起合作的人，包括
Barbiglia.
And then UCB was just about to come on the air, and they came down to GW and did a show
at GW.
It was like a big improv festival, and it was the first time I saw those guys, and my mind fully
exploded.
Did they do Bucket of Truth?
Bucket of Truth?
What's Bucket of Truth?
巴巴利亚（Barbiglia）。然后UCB（直立人喜剧剧团）当时正准备开播，他们来到华盛顿大学（GW）做了一场演出。那就像是一个大型即兴喜剧节，那是我第一次看到那些家伙，我的脑子彻底炸裂了。他们演了《真相桶》（Bucket of Truth）吗？《真相桶》？什么是《真相桶》？
It was Little Donnie.
Remember Little Donnie's?
It was like Besser had the sketched this little kid with a huge...
huge guy.
But I saw that and then moved to the city that summer,
or started going to the city,
we did a workshop at UCB and,
Will, you know Owen Burke.
那是《小唐尼》（Little Donnie）。还记得小唐尼吗？贝瑟（Besser）演了一个留着大……大块头的小男孩。但我看了那个演出，那年夏天就搬到了城里，或者说开始经常去城里，我们在UCB参加了一个工作坊，然后，维尔（Will），你认识欧文·伯克（Owen Burke）。
You guys all know Owen.
Owen was my brother's roommate in college,
and Owen had just started at UCB.
So I started going to UCB,
started going to ASCAT as a fan, you know,
and could not believe what I was seeing.
I agree.
I had the same, first of all,
你们都认识欧文。欧文是我哥哥在大学时的室友，欧文刚开始在UCB工作。所以我开始去UCB，作为粉丝开始去观看ASSCAT（UCB的周日长篇即兴秀），你知道的，简直不敢相信我眼前看到的一切。我同意。我也有同感，首先，
I had the same sensation.
I saw them do Bucket of Truth in 1996.
They just moved from Chicago.
Can you tell me what bucket of truth is?
It was a sketch show that they did.
And they did it downstairs at the West Bank on 42nd Street,
the restaurant, they had that little space down there.
And I was like, what?
我也有过那种震撼的感觉。我1996年看他们演《真相桶》。他们刚从芝加哥搬来。你能告诉我什么是真相桶吗？那是他们演的一个小品秀。他们当时在42街西岸餐厅（West Bank）的楼下演，那家餐厅楼下有个小空间。当时我就想：什么？
And it was Walsh and Amy and Besser and Ian Roberts.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Like watching what these guys did.
So I loved it.
And then they started doing it, they started doing Ascad,
that other plays solo arts on 17th Street
before they moved into their theater
and I would go every Sunday
演员有沃尔什（Walsh）、艾米（Amy）、贝瑟和伊恩·罗伯茨（Ian Roberts），当时我就想：靠，这什么鬼？看这些家伙的表演简直太棒了。然后他们开始演，在他们搬进自己的剧场之前，他们在17街的另一个独角艺术剧场开始演Ascad，我每个周日都会去
and J.B., you remember my old roommate, Duff.
I had lived with Duff and I'd been roommates years,
but you know Duff too, right?
I know Duff, yeah, a little bit through Owen and...
Through Owen.
And so I said to Owen and Duff,
I go, you guys got to...
I said, let's go to this thing and see these guys
还有J.B.，你还记得我以前的室友达夫（Duff）吗？我和达夫住过，我们当了好几年的室友，你也认识达夫，对吧？我认识达夫，是的，通过欧文稍微认识一点……通过欧文。所以我对欧文和达夫说，我说你们得去……我说，我们去看看这个演出，去瞧瞧这帮家伙。
and Owen came along to...
Oh, wow.
I brought him to his first UCB show
and he ended up as artistic director of UCB.
Yeah.
Isn't that wild?
Owen Bird.
Yeah.
然后欧文也一起来了……哦，哇。我带他去看了他的第一场UCB演出，结果他最后成了UCB的艺术总监。对啊。是不是很疯狂？欧文·伯克。对啊。
as well.
Funny, good man.
And that was sort of,
so I started coming and we would go and I was, you know,
I went to solo arts once or twice and saw all those shows
and then would go to the theater at 22nd Street
and like sit on the side,
you know, wait, sit on the side and look up.
也是。一个有趣的好人。所以，我开始常去，我们会去，我（你知道的）去过一两次独角艺术剧场，看过所有那些演出，然后会去22街的剧场，坐在旁边，你知道的，等一下，坐在旁边抬头看。
And it was like all these people, you know,
who were, you know, who were just popping on Conan and...
Oh, it's like Glazer and Tina and McKay would be there and all those guys.
Yeah, it just was like, and as soon as I,
literally as soon as I saw it, the first,
did that sketch, little sketch show
and then joined the improv group.
My sophomore year was like, done.
那感觉就像所有这些人，你知道的，那些在柯南（Conan）节目里崭露头角的人……哦，就像格雷泽（Glazer）、蒂娜（Tina）和麦凯（McKay）都会在那里，还有所有那些人。是的，那种感觉就是，而且一看到，真的，我一看到那个，先是做了那个小品秀，然后加入了即兴喜剧团。我的大学二年级就像是，结束了。
I'll do back to sort of what you're saying.
I was like, I'll do anything.
Get me close to this.
I'll do anything.
But speak more about, you know,
because I'm just, I'm most fascinated with people at that age
where you need to or you think you need to commit to a career.
And you have to really think about making rent and feeding yourself.
回到你刚才的话题。我当时想：我什么都愿意做。让我离这个近一点，我什么都愿意做。但多聊聊，你知道的，因为我最着迷的是那种年纪的人，你觉得你需要或者认为你需要致力于一项职业。你必须真正考虑付房租和养活自己。
And like you're out from the nest
at home.
And so you're at this opportunity, an incredible university.
You haven't really picked an occupation, an industry, a path.
At what point did you feel like, oh, okay, there's enough momentum going in this lane
where I need not continue to consider other means of support?
Well, for me, after a silver spoon, I just wanted to have fun.
You know what I mean?
而且你已经离开家里的温巢了。所以你正处于这样一个机会面前，在一所不可思议的大学里。你还没有真正选定一个职业、一个行业、一条道路。你在哪个时刻觉得，哦，好吧，这条路上的势头已经足够强劲了，我不需要再考虑其他谋生手段了？嗯，对我来说，在经历了银汤匙的生活之后，我只想找点乐子。你知道我的意思吗？
After the spoon.
This is why I'm so curious about it because it was like I'd had this momentum since I was a little kid.
But I still at 18, I thought, well, is it going to last?
Maybe I should study something else that's a little bit more reliable.
Well, so going back.
So the other thing, my connection to Jason a bit is that you're originally from Rye, right?
Or your family.
So I'm from Rye, New York.
在汤匙之后。这就是为什么我对这个很好奇，因为我感觉自己从小就带着这种势头。但我到18岁时还是在想，这能持久吗？也许我应该学点别的、更靠谱一点的东西。嗯，所以回到正题。还有一件事，我和杰森（Jason）的一点渊源是，你原本是来自莱伊（Rye）的，对吧？或者说你的家人。所以我来自纽约州莱伊。
Oh, no way.
Yeah.
So, you know, I grew up with.
plenty of privilege.
So I went to, I never had, like, the privilege was that I could sort of be like, what do I want to do?
And I went to college and I started, and I, you know, school was never exactly my thing.
I was fine at it.
But as soon as I started doing improv and comedy and sketch, I was like, I'll do anything, like, I'll print, you know, like, I'll go anywhere at any hour to get this done.
哦，不会吧。对啊。所以，你知道的，我是在优渥的环境中长大的。所以我去过，我从来没有过，那种特权就是我可以有点像是，我想做什么就做什么。我上了大学，然后开始，而且我，你知道的，学校从来都不是我的强项。我应付得过去。但一接触到即兴喜剧、喜剧和小品，我就觉得：我什么都愿意做，比如，我会去印传单，你知道的，为了完成这个，我随时随地都愿意去。
And when I moved to New York, I had, I did have the real, the privilege of, you know, the, the privilege of, you know,
knowing that I could fall back.
Like, if it didn't work,
I could go get a job somewhere.
Like, it was going to be okay.
Yeah.
But it was, the thing I feel so lucky about is that I had such a clear,
I knew I knew I wanted,
当我搬到纽约时，我确实拥有真正的特权，你知道的，那种知道自己有退路的特权。如果行不通，我可以去别的地方找工作。一切都会没事的。是的。但我最庆幸的是，我有着如此清晰的目标，我知道自己想要，
I knew as soon as I started doing it,
this is all I wanted to do.
And any work, now, the question of whether I was going to make it
is the intangible.
Right.
But I think the idea for me was like,
well, I'm going to regret the fuck out of this if I don't try.
Right.
我一接触到它就知道，这就是我唯一想做的事。至于能不能成功，这还是个未知数。没错。但我觉得我当时的念头是：如果我不去尝试，我他妈一定会后悔死的。没错。
You recognize that it was something that really fed your soul,
that you were decent at it, you liked the out of boys,
and it was sort of self-perpetuating.
Yeah, and it's never, it's never waned, at least for me.
Which is interesting, because, J.B., you do have that as well.
At the same time, this was your thing,
since before you can remember doing anything else, really,
since you were a little kid, there was never like,
你意识到这是某种真正能滋养你灵魂的东西，你在这方面还算可以，你喜欢听到别人的夸奖，而且它有一种自我延续的力量。是的，而且它从未，至少对我和我而言从未减弱过。这很有趣，因为，J.B.，你也是这样。与此同时，这就是你的毕生所求，从你记事起就在做别的事之前，真的，自从你还是个小孩的时候，从来就没有过那种，
hey, I'm going to try my hand at this.
You were in it.
You were always in it, right?
Right? I mean, I don't mean to say that you, yeah, I'm talking to you.
I'm not saying that you didn't have a choice, but that was your, in a lot of ways, it was your job.
It became your passion.
Yeah, I had realized that I was halfway decent at something before I needed to have something that I was halfway decent at.
And I think for you, so on that.
嘿，我要去尝试一下这行。你已经身在其中了。你一直都在里面，对吧？对吧？我的意思是，我不是说你，是的，我在跟你说话。我不是说你没得选，但那在很大程度上就是你的工作。它成了你的激情所在。是的，我意识到在需要找到一个自己半斤八两的领域之前，我已经在这上面有点天赋了。而且我觉得对于你来说，就凭这一点。
And you were cute as a button.
Hey, Nick, stop it.
God, were you cute?
Never in the chat.
Oh, no, no.
Not another rhythm connection.
I run too.
Enough.
你长得像钮扣一样可爱。嘿，尼克，住手。天哪，你当时可爱吗？聊天里从来没有过。哦，不，不。又是一个节奏联系。我也跑。够了。
But, J.B., you had that second gear for you.
The thing what you found was when directing
and seeing you light up at this stage of your life
when you talk about directing is the same way,
I think that I certainly did a nick,
the way you describe it, discovering this thing where you go,
I love this, I got to do this, I'll print flyers,
I'll do whatever it takes.
但是，J.B.，你拥有那种第二档的动力。你发现的事情是，当你谈论导演时，你那种在人生的这个阶段因导演而双眼放光的时刻，和我以及尼克的感觉是一样的，正如你所描述的那样，发现了这样一件事，让你觉得：我太爱这个了，我非得做这个不可，我去印传单，付出任何代价我都愿意。
True.
You kind of have it for directing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right, like 10, 12 years ago or 15 years ago.
Right, and like anyone out there, you know,
if you were like,
lucky enough to get paid a little bit to do something that you would pay somebody else to do,
right? Because you love it so much. That's the sort of fuel that can really travel you into
确实。你对导演也有这种感觉。对，对，对。没错，就像10、12年前或者15年前一样。没错，就像局外人一样，你知道的，如果你足够幸运，能因为做一件哪怕别人花钱请你、你也会倒贴钱去做的事而获得一点报酬，对吧？因为你太爱它了。这就是那种真正能推动你走向
success and longevity and instead of just punching a clock. You know, if it's something that
really is passionate. Nick, just quickly, did you do, because you've worked with a lot of great people,
we mentioned Mitch Hurwitz and obviously Malaney. You've had a lot of great partners and collaborators.
is another funny dude that we know that we all connect with is John Levinstein, who worked on a
show.
Super, super funny.
One of the funniest most bizarre men in the world.
I know.
成功和长青，而不是仅仅去按时打卡的动力。你知道的，如果这是一件真正充满激情的事。尼克，简单说一下，你做过吗？因为你合作过很多优秀的人，我们提到了米奇·赫维茨（Mitch Hurwitz），显然还有木兰尼（Mulaney）。你有很多优秀的搭档和合作者。我们认识的另一个有趣的家伙、我们都有联系的人是约翰·莱文斯坦（John Levinstein），他曾参与过一个节目的制作。超级超级有趣。世界上最有趣、最古怪的人之一。我知道。
And honestly, I just have to say it since we just mentioned it, the Kroll Show is one of my
favorite shows of all time.
Thank you, Sean.
Truly, I mean.
So, it's so funny.
And Levinstein was a big part of that, right?
Yeah, he was the showrunner, and he had come, we hired it.
I mean, I met him doing this cartoon called Life in Times of Tim.
老实说，既然我们刚刚提到了，我必须得说，《克罗尔秀》（The Kroll Show）是我有史以来最喜欢的节目之一。谢谢你，肖恩。真的，我是说。太搞笑了。莱文斯坦在其中占了很大比重，对吧？对，他是剧集运作人，他是来……我们雇了他。我的意思是，我是通过制作一部叫《蒂姆的生活与时代》（The Life and Times of Tim）的动画认识他的。
Oh, yeah.
And Jiles, that's how I met Jiles.
Also with Pete Jiles.
Yeah, that's how I met Jiles originally.
Sweet Pete Jowles.
Yeah, and one of the great voices.
Talk about him.
You think we got some gravel.
哦，是的。吉尔斯（Jiles），我就是这么认识吉尔斯的。也是通过皮特·吉尔斯（Pete Jiles）。对，我最早就是这么认识吉尔斯的。可爱的皮特·吉尔斯。对，拥有最棒的嗓音之一。聊聊他吧。觉得我们的声音有点沙哑。
That motherfucker.
Pete Jals.
You can catch him, you can hear him everywhere.
Yeah.
It's the World Series on Fox.
Pete Jiles.
So it is, yeah.
那个混蛋。皮特·吉尔斯。你到处都能听到他的声音。对。福克斯频道的棒球世界大赛。对。皮特·吉尔斯。所以确实是，
I mean, I, hey, by the way, Jason, I'm so sorry Zootopia didn't work out.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm the next time on the V-O stuff.
They can all be winners on the V-O stuff.
I do envy what you guys can do with V-O.
I still feel like I'm just leaving voicemail messages.
I have no idea what the fuck I'm doing.
Jason, I forgot to tell you last week I was out east,
我的意思是，我，嘿，顺便说一句，杰森，我很遗憾《疯狂动物城》（Zootopia）没能成功。对。是的，下次配音的时候。配音这行可不能保证个个都是赢家。我确实很羡慕你们能做配音工作。我感觉自己就像是在留语音信箱。我根本不知道自己他妈在干什么。杰森，我上周忘了告诉你，我去东部了，
and I was out for dinner with my little guy, Denny, who's five.
And there's a couple sitting next to us,
and they're talking about,
and they've got like a seven-year-old girl,
and they're talking about Zootopia.
And my guy, Denny, goes,
I saw Zootopia too, and they're like,
we love Zootopia 2.
我和我五岁的小家伙丹尼（Denny）出去吃晚饭。旁边坐着一对夫妇，他们带着一个七岁左右的小女孩，在谈论《疯狂动物城》。我的小家伙丹尼说：“我也看过《疯狂动物城》”，他们就说：“我们超喜欢《疯狂动物城2》”。
And he goes, and he comes up, and he goes,
Dad, can I tell him?
I go, tell him what?
He goes, about Jason.
And I go, sure, and he goes,
my dad's friend, Jason, is the voice of Nick.
My son is five.
It was so sweet.
然后他跑过来对我说：“爸爸，我能告诉他们吗？”我问：“告诉他们什么？”他说：“关于杰森的事。”我说：“当然可以。”他说：“我爸爸的朋友杰森是尼克的配音。”我儿子才五岁。太甜了。
How about I'm just excited that he knows my name.
I know.
I love that.
I love that little guy.
Isn't it?
Nick, can I ask about growing up
because we touched on that a little bit
我只想说，他知道我的名字我就已经很兴奋了。我知道。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢那个小家伙了。是不是？是不是？尼克，我能问问你成长经历吗？因为我们刚才稍微聊到了这个，
and I think it's fascinating
and when I read this,
I laughed out loud that you grew up in Rye, New York
and your parents sent a limo
to pick you up from school?
Is that every day?
No, no, no, every once in a while.
When you're good.
我觉得这太迷人了。当我读到这个时，我忍不住笑出了声，你是在纽约州莱伊长大的，你父母曾派豪华轿车去学校接你？是每天都这样吗？不，不，不，偶尔。当你表现好的时候。
So it wasn't...
That made me laugh out loud
when I read that.
I'm like, is that true?
Yeah, it was like different strokes, right?
Like, you just...
Yeah, exactly.
It's true.
所以并不是……我读到那个的时候忍不住笑出声来。我想：这是真的吗？对，就像《不同的 strokes》（Different Strokes）里那样，对吧？就像……是的，exactly。是真的。
Well, what happened to all those limos?
You remember we used to see stretch limos?
everywhere. Where did they go?
I kind of thought about bringing it back this year when we went to the big
award show the other. Oh my God. That was so
all funny. I thought wouldn't it be funny to pull up
to like the Academy Awards in a white stretch limo?
Oh my God. But I want to know where they went literally
好吧，那些豪华轿车都去哪儿了？你还记得我们以前到处都能看到加长豪华轿车吗？它们都去哪儿了？我前几天去参加那个大型颁奖典礼时，甚至还考虑过今年把这传统带回来。哦，天哪。太搞笑了。我想开着一辆白色加长豪华轿车去奥斯卡颁奖典礼，这难道不是很酷吗？哦，天哪。但我真的想知道它们都去哪儿了，
like you say I guess scrap metal yards or do they put them
their waymos now. They're all waymos. They're all
waymos. They're all. They're all playing in Europe.
You talked to them. You talked to
you talk to. That's a great joke.
So you had to, there were occasions where you had to
be driven to school.
It just is what it is.
就像你说的，我猜是送去废品回收站了，或者现在它们都变成Waymo无人车了？全都是Waymo。全都在欧洲跑着呢。你跟他们聊过。你跟……你跟……这是个绝妙的笑话。所以你有时候确实得坐车去上学，事情就是这样。
My dad, my dad, it's like,
the internet,
the internet is real,
loves to speculate on my,
my dad,
his business,
fascinating business,
fascinating man,
我爸，我爸，就像，互联网——互联网真的很真实——喜欢对我和我爸以及他的生意进行各种猜测，一份迷人的生意，一个迷人的人，
built incredible business.
Do you guys, Jay,
do you know about his dad?
No, please.
I didn't either.
And when I read about it, Nick,
I understood 10% of it.
So can you please explain a drug dealer?
建立了一家不可思议的公司。你们，杰，你知道他爸是做什么的吗？不知道，请讲。我也不知道。当我读到关于这的事时，尼克，我只能听懂10%的。所以你能解释一下什么是军火商的毒贩吗？
What is it?
Consultants.
He deals drugs.
He dealt drugs to arms dealers.
Got it.
That's lucrative.
Because it's two different, you know, you've got to find the guy who's going to come in between him.
Was that what that Jonah Hill movie was about those guys?
那是什么？顾问。他贩毒。他向军火商贩毒。明白了。这很赚钱。因为这是两件不同的事，你知道的，你得找到那个能在中间牵线搭桥的人。乔纳·希尔（Jonah Hill）演的那部关于那些家伙的电影是讲这个的吗？
Remember the movie?
Oh, yeah.
I like that movie.
With Nick Cage?
War dogs.
Yes, War Dogs.
Was that they were that they were doing?
I want to see that.
还记得那部电影吗？哦，对。我喜欢那部电影。尼古拉斯·凯奇演的？《军火贩》（War Dogs）。对，就是《军火贩》。他们当时干的就是这个吗？我想看那部电影。
But so anyway, he built this, he sort of did, the larger umbrella would be like risk mitigation.
So like it started as like corporate investigations, due diligence, and during the 80s,
It was like Wall Street takeover, private,
all those hostile takeovers like doing,
like Ivan Boski and all those kinds of characters.
And then it was dictators, like Saddam,
like the Kuwaiti government hired him to find Saddam Hussein's money.
Wow.
不管怎样，他建立了这个，他做的——大致的范围可以说是风险缓解。所以就像是以企业调查、尽职调查起步的，在80年代，那正是华尔街收购、私人并购的时期，所有那些恶意收购，就像伊凡·博斯基（Ivan Boesky）和所有那些角色。后来是独裁者，比如萨达姆，科威特政府雇他去寻找萨达姆·侯赛因的钱。哇。
And Baby Doc Duvalier and Haiti and the Marcos.
I love baby Doc Duvalier.
Now you're really going into it.
Me and Malaney were trying to write a movie.
The dog handles Kimmel, handles Fallon,
handles Colbert.
James Dixon, baby Dixon.
Baby doll, that's Baby Doll. That's Baby Doll.
还有海地的“娃娃医生”杜瓦利埃（Baby Doc Duvalier）以及马科斯家族。我喜欢娃娃医生杜瓦利埃。现在你可真深入进去了。我和木兰尼曾试图写一部电影，关于吉米·吉尔（Kimmel）、吉米·法伦（Fallon）、斯蒂芬·科尔伯特（Colbert）的经纪人，詹姆斯·狄克逊（James Dixon），娃娃狄克逊（Baby Dixon）。娃娃，那是娃娃。那是娃娃。
Wait a second, Nick.
Now that I think, did Duff write a book
about your dad's company?
He may have, yes.
He may have at some point, yes.
Yeah.
And so he, and then he's gone on to continue to sort of work
in various versions of that business,
等一下，尼克。现在我想起来，达夫写过一本关于你父亲的公司的书吗？他可能写过，是的。他可能在某个时候写过，是的。对。而且他后来继续从事该业务的各种衍生版本，
and he and my brother have a company called K2 now,
which continues to do different versions of investigations
and risk mitigation and security and stuff like that.
And they make great skis.
I know everybody out there likes slal...
Slalom.
Hey, but Nick, you know, I do want to say it,
他和我的兄弟现在有一家叫K2的公司，继续从事各种版本的调查、风险缓解和安全之类的工作。而且他们生产很棒的滑雪板。我知道每个人都喜欢回转滑雪板……回转滑雪板。嘿，但是尼克，我必须要说，
and I'm glad you talked about it,
because you didn't decide what your dad did
or how you were born, and your dad started a company,
and he was successful at what he did.
And so I like that you just, you talk about it openly, because what the fuck are you going to do?
Yeah.
Right?
You don't need to apologize.
我很高兴你谈到了这一点，因为你没得选择你父亲是做什么的或者你是怎么出生的，你父亲白手起家创办了一家公司，他在自己的事业上很成功。所以我喜欢你能够公开谈论它，因为你他妈能怎么办呢？对吧？你不需要道歉。
The internet will find you.
No, I know, but you don't need to apologize for where you came from.
What are you supposed to do?
Right, exactly.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I mean, that's, no, but it is.
I just got, I mean, I feel like I got real lucky.
互联网会找到你的。不，我知道，但你不需要为你的出身道歉。你还能怎么办？对，没错。谢谢。是的。我的意思是，那，不，但确实如此。我觉得我真的很幸运。
I got dealt a real good hand.
Of course, you did.
But you, as I've said, I've known you 20, 25 years.
you work really hard.
You create a lot of stuff.
You create a lot of stuff on your own.
You didn't have family in show business.
And you did it all through hard work and talent.
我拿到了一手好牌。你当然拿到了。但是正如我所说，我认识你20、25年了。你工作非常努力。你创作了很多东西。你靠自己创作了很多东西。你家里又没有人在娱乐圈。你全凭辛勤的工作和天赋做到了这一切。
So, you know, fuck everybody.
But he sounds, that sounds really fascinating.
Get them to investigate Bateman, please.
The kinds of, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Just look into it.
But, Jason, why do you keep going to Grand Cayman?
Answer that.
所以，你知道的，管其他人去死吧。不过听起来，那听起来真的很迷人。请让他们去调查一下贝特曼（Bateman），拜托。那种，不，不，不，不，不，不。只要查一查就行。只要查一查就行。不过，杰森，你为什么一直去大开曼群岛？回答这个问题。
Listen, these people are so kind.
You're doing the firm cosplay?
But yeah, the kind of connections and know how he's got,
I just, that's like up there with, I would, if I could pick a new career,
if I could go back in time, if I was like 17 and I would like to get recruited by the CIA.
Oh, yeah, you have, you have CIA vibes written all over.
I would love to be somebody in my mid-50s, like, well, I'm in my late 50s now,
that is still,
听着，这些人太友善了。你在搞《黑钱胜地》（The Ozark）的角色扮演吗？不过是的，他拥有的那些人脉和专业知识，那简直就像——如果我可以选择一门新职业，如果能时光倒流，如果我17岁而且想被中情局招募的话。哦，是的，你身上从头到脚都散发着中情局的气质。我很想成为那种五十多岁的人，就像——好吧，我现在快六十岁了——依然能够，
like,
I would like to be able to hold that secret from,
because you're not supposed to be able to tell your wife.
From your family?
Yeah.
Right?
I mean, if you're really good.
You want to hold more secrets from your family?
就像，我希望自己能把那个秘密对——因为你本来就不应该告诉你的妻子。对家人保密？对。对吧？我的意思是，如果你真的够专业的话。你想对家人隐瞒更多秘密吗？
I've got a little more room.
I found a little more room on my drive.
Wait, Jibby, we just went through your morning routine.
You think that your CIA ready?
Are you fucking kidding?
No, that's what you do in the CIA.
You watch the end of a Dodger game.
Yeah.
我的硬盘里还有点空间。我发现硬盘里还能挤出一点空间。等等，吉比（Jibby），我们刚刚聊过你的晨间日常。你觉得你准备好进中情局了吗？你开什么国际玩笑？不，你在中情局就是这么干的。你看着道奇队比赛结束。对。
No way this guy's a spy.
Look how dummy is?
They're like, how do we kill that Bateman agent?
He's at the golf club.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Were you going to say, Nick,
were you going to say you and Malaney
这家伙绝对不可能是间谍。你看他多蠢？他们会想：我们怎么干掉那个贝特曼特工？他在高尔夫俱乐部。我们马上回来。现在，言归正传。你刚才要说，尼克，你刚才是不是要说你和木兰尼
were working on a script about it, or no?
Was that what you're going to say?
We were working on a script.
We sold a movie called Most Glorious Friend,
and it was, you know those like Nigerian email,
Prince email scams?
Yeah.
They're fucking scams?
正在写一个关于这个的剧本，还是没有？那是你想说的吗？我们确实在写一个剧本。我们卖出了一部名为《最光荣的朋友》（Most Glorious Friend）的电影，是关于，你知道那种尼日利亚王子诈骗邮件吗？对。那是他妈的骗局吗？
Yeah.
Oh, Willie.
The premise of the movie was like, this was the, this time it was real.
And it was going to be Tracy Morgan as the deposed dictator of a country called Lyrobia.
And his name was Lil Moe.
And that was so like a couple college kids respond to the email.
And then like Tracy Morgan shows up being like, where's my money?
And we pitched it out with Tracy.
对。哦，威利。电影的设定是：这一次，那是真的。主演将是特雷西·摩根（Tracy Morgan），饰演一个名叫莱罗比亚（Lyrobia）的国家的被废独裁者。他的名字叫小莫（Lil Moe）。设定就是几个大学生回复了邮件。然后特雷西·摩根出现并质问：我的钱呢？我们和特雷西一起推销了这个创意。
It's so, it was genuine.
very, I mean, I was probably structurally.
I mean, we had no idea we were doing.
We just sat there reading Save the Cat by the Chapter and then trying to write off of that.
Save the Cat is a screenwriting book.
That's so, that's so fun.
That's such a fun taking.
Scher and I worked on this thing years ago, Mike Schur, we called the Ambassador,
太棒了，这很真实。我的意思是，在结构上我可能……我的意思是，我们根本不知道自己在干什么。我们只是坐在那里一章一章地读《救猫咪》（Save the Cat），然后试着据此写作。《救猫咪》是一本编剧书。太有意思了。这构思太有趣了。舍尔（Scher）和我多年前写过这样一个东西，迈克·舍尔（Mike Schur），我们叫它《大使》，
but basically he's too dumb to kill.
He's the son of his senator and they make him envoy to the EU to ruin all their trade deals.
and then he's like getting chased like born
but he doesn't realize he's being like he's being chased
he keeps going go around
you both all three of you guys could be spies
you guys should be like 50s
the worst spies post cold war spies
但基本上就是他笨到死不了。他是一个参议员的儿子，他们派他去欧盟担任特使来搞砸所有的贸易协议。然后他被追杀，就像杰森·伯恩那样，但他根本没意识到自己被追杀了，他一直说“绕过去”。你们两个，不，你们三个都可以去当间谍，你们应该去当那种五十多岁的、最烂的冷战后间谍，
right like spies like you
spies like us
yeah spies like us but there's a
it's just how it's pronounced at the end
wait so this this made me laugh too
because Big Mouth is about, like you said, you and your friend,
puberty 13 years old.
But I read your sister, Vanessa, is now a professional puberty educator.
对吧？就像间谍，像我们这样的间谍……对，就像我们这样的间谍，只不过发音在最后有点不一样。等等，这个也把我逗笑了，因为《大嘴》（Big Mouth）讲的是，正如你所说，你和你的朋友在13岁经历青春期。但我看到你的姐姐瓦妮萨（Vanessa）现在是一名职业青春期教育家？
Yeah.
What does that even mean?
What does that mean?
So, yeah, my sister Vanessa is a, yeah, she became an expert in puberty.
She started a thing called Dynamo Girl a number of years ago.
And it's like after school program for sports for girls.
And then as she was teaching these young girls, like they, as they got older and started
going through puberty, she realized that there was just a ton of, there was just like an empty
对。那到底是什么意思？那是什么意思？所以，是的，我姐姐瓦妮萨是一名，对，她成了青春期方面的专家。她几年前创办了一个叫“活力女孩”（Dynamo Girl）的项目。那是一个针对女孩的课后体育项目。然后，当她在教这些年轻女孩时，随着她们年龄增长并开始经历青春期，她意识到这里存在着巨大的……
spot in that and sort of the education around that and like having parents and kids understand
what's going on. So, I mean, it's a crazy synergy. But I think it just speaks to a little bit of,
I guess our experience, you know, she's two years older than me of going through that period
of life together. It was of interest. Like, we had those books, like, what's happening to me?
You know, those like groovy 70s books
with like body, drawings of the body.
And so we were...
Are you there, God, it's me, Margaret?
空白，也就是关于这方面的教育以及让父母和孩子了解到底发生了什么。所以，我的意思是，这是一种疯狂的协同效应。但我觉得这也稍微体现了我们的经历，你知道的，她比我大两岁，我们一起经历了人生的那个阶段。这很有趣。就像我们读过那些书，比如《我身体里发生了什么？》（What's Happening to Me?），你知道的，那些带有人体插图的70年代时髦书籍。所以我们……《上帝，你在吗？是我，玛格丽特》（Are You There God? It's Me, Margaret）？
Yeah, like all of that stuff, I think, loomed large for us.
And so it became an interest for both of us.
And she's like, so she's kind of writing about parenting
and that kind of stuff.
She's got four kids.
And then, is she the one, who's the one married to the men in Blazers?
That's my sister Vanessa's married to Roger Bennett for Men and Blazers.
Yeah, I know those.
对，诸如此类的一切，我觉得对我们影响深远。所以这成了我们两个人的兴趣所在。她现在在写关于育儿之类的内容。她有四个孩子。然后，她是那个吗？谁是嫁给“西装男”（Men in Blazers）的那个人？我姐姐瓦妮萨嫁给了“西装男”的罗杰·贝内特（Roger Bennett）。哦，我知道他们。
I love those guys.
That's cool.
And all your siblings, there's four of you.
Yeah.
Are you all funny people?
Like, are you all?
I think so.
I don't know how it works in your family,
我超喜欢那帮家伙。太酷了。你们所有的兄弟姐妹，你们有四个。对。你们全家都很搞笑吗？比如，你们全都是吗？我想是的。我不知道在你们家里是怎么样的，
but, like, I don't,
I think it's pretty rare that someone comes out of a family that isn't all,
if they're funny, that isn't also funny.
Right, right.
My brother's, my brother's really funny and my sister's,
yeah, I think it was in the family.
There was a sense of humor.
Did you guys get it from mom or dad?
但是，我觉得，如果一个家庭里有人很搞笑，那全家人也都挺搞笑，这种情况其实挺罕见的。对，对。我兄弟，我兄弟真的很搞笑，我姐姐也是，是的，我觉得这是家族基因。幽默感是遗传的。你们是从爸爸还是妈妈那里遗传的？
They're both pretty funny.
My dad's funny.
And my mom's got a very good sense of humor,
especially having to deal with me tell jokes about mom.
Like she, you know, she's like, people tell me, am I upset about the jokes about moms?
And I'd say, I'm not.
Okay.
They're both fair enough, huh?
他们两个都挺搞笑的。我爸很搞笑。我妈妈非常有幽默感，尤其是得应付我讲关于妈妈的笑话。就像她，你知道的，她会说，有人问我：你对那些关于妈妈的笑话生气吗？我会说：我才不生气。好吧。他们俩都挺开明的，对吧？
Yeah.
But though, it's a funny family, I think.
But I think, but me kind of being like, no, I'm going to go be a comedian.
Yeah.
Everyone was like, huh, there was definitely, it wasn't like, well, of course you're going to, you know.
You know, Jimmy Valli.
Yes.
Jimmy Valley used to have...
对。不过，我们是个搞笑的家庭，我觉得。但我选择说“不，我要去当个喜剧演员”的时候。对，每个人都觉得：啊？这绝对不是那种“哦，你当然会去……”的反应。你知道吉米·瓦利（Jimmy Valley）吗？是的。吉米·瓦利以前经常……
Another vet Levinecy, another rested guy.
Yeah, another rest of the great Jimmy Valley,
who's one of the all-time...
Yeah, one of the all-time funniest
and has jokes that nobody else can think of.
That are just so...
God, I fucking love Jimmy Valley.
Anyway, he used to always say, he'd say, like,
另一个莱文斯坦（Levinecy）式的传奇人物，另一个安息的伟人。对，另一个安息的伟大的吉米·瓦利，他是史上最……对，史上最搞笑的人之一，而且总能想出别人绝对想不出来的笑话。那些笑话简直太……天哪，我他妈太爱吉米·瓦利了。不管怎样，他以前总是说，他说：
you know, if you come...
We were talking about somebody,
he said, yeah, this guy sort of came from a good family.
He goes, he had more to lose.
And I go, what do you mean?
He goes, well, in a way, he could have gone into...
He could have been a lawyer.
He could have been a good school and stuff,
你知道，如果你出身……我们当时在谈论某个人，他说：是的，这家伙算是出身于一个好家庭。他说：他输不起。我问：你这话什么意思？他说：嗯，从某种意义上说，他本可以去……他本可以当个律师。他本可以上一所好学校之类的，
and he risked it all to do this.
If you come from nothing, you've got nothing to lose.
A hundred percent.
And I was like, oh, that's interesting.
I never looked at that way.
It's so true, yeah.
Well, Nick, you're so multi-talented,
and you've done so many different jobs
而他为了做这个赌上了一切。如果你一无所有，你就没什么可失去的。百分之百。当时我就想：哦，这很有趣。我从来没那个角度想过。确实如此，对吧。好吧，尼克，你多才多艺，做过那么多不同的工作，
in the structure of things.
How do you decide what to do next?
And, like, what would the perfect next five years look like?
I mean, I don't know how strategic you are.
I imagine.
And I don't mean that as a pejorative, you know.
Sure.
It takes a certain amount of planning to get things down in this business.
在各种架构中。你接下来是怎么决定要做什么的？还有，未来完美的五年会是什么样子？我的意思是，我不知道你的战略性有多强。我猜。我这话没有贬义，你知道的。当然。在这个行业里把事情落实需要相当程度的规划。
Yeah.
I mean, you got, look, he's got roommates out April 17th.
He's got mating season on May 22nd.
Sean found the file.
I found it.
Sean finally found the email.
You have 100% with Sam Richardson and Jason and Jennifer.
And that's another Netflix.
对。我的意思是，你看，他4月17日有《室友》（Roommates）要上。他5月22日有《交配季》（Mating Season）要上。肖恩找到文件了。我找到了。肖恩终于找到那封邮件了。你和萨姆·理查森（Sam Richardson）、杰森以及詹妮弗合作了100%的项目。那又是另一部网飞作品。
I mean, you have tons of stuff coming out.
It's so exciting.
So, by the way, Nick, you need to know that Scotty was just off camera going,
I just bumped it up in your email.
He just held out
He just held up a date
Scott he was like
Do you want me to stop warming the cupcake
我的意思是，你有一大堆作品要上映。太令人兴奋了。顺便说一句，尼克，你得知道斯科蒂（Scotty）刚才在镜头外说：“我刚刚把这个置顶到你的邮件里了。”他刚举起——他刚举起一个日期，斯科蒂就像是：你想让我停止加热纸杯蛋糕
And get to your dates?
Hotmail.com backslash mail
Can we
We actually met it on hot mail
Anyway so that's just a little joke
Just a small joke
It wasn't Sarandos's party
It was on hot mail yeah
然后转到你的日程表吗？Hotmail.com斜杠邮件 我们其实是在Hotmail上认识的 不管怎样 这只是个小笑话 只是个小笑话 那不是萨兰多斯（Sarandos）的派对 是在Hotmail上 耶
And there just felt like a comedy connection there
Yeah
So my strategy
is I keep
And I feel like honestly
you guys also do a lot and produce a lot.
Like, I keep a number of balls in the air
that are all at different stages of development.
感觉那里有一种喜剧上的联系 对啊 所以我的策略是，我一直……而且我觉得老实说，你们俩也做很多事、制作很多节目。就像，我手里同时保持着好几个处于不同开发阶段的项目。
And so, you know, I'm...
And so I think I like this show...
Mating season is the follow-up to Big Mouth,
and it's about animals, dating, and falling in love in the woods.
So it feels like a natural sort of progression of that.
And I've been working with my partners, Mark, and Andrew Jen on that.
It's me, Zach Woods, June Diane Rayfeel,
Sabrina Jalise.
所以，你知道，我在……而且我觉得我很喜欢这个节目……《交配季》是《大嘴》的衍生后续，讲的是动物们在树林里约会和坠入爱河的故事。所以这感觉像是自然而然的延续。我和我的搭档马克、安德鲁·詹（Andrew Jen）一直在为此努力。里面有我、扎克·伍兹（Zach Woods）、琼·黛安·拉斐尔（June Diane Rayfeel）、萨布丽娜·贾利斯（Sabrina Jalise）。
It's like, you know,
like a...
Fun.
Fun hangout,
kind of in the vein
of like an animated version
of friends or...
I can't remember any of the other
就像是一个……有趣。有趣的闲逛喜剧，有点类似于动画版的《老友记》或者……我记不得其他任何
any of those other NBC shows.
No, can't even.
But you know that sort of...
That genre.
No, I mean, none really...
Oh, Seinfeld.
There was signs...
Yeah, Seinfeld.
任何其他NBC的节目了。不，甚至想不起来。但你知道那种……那种类型。不，我的意思是，其实没有……哦，《宋飞传》（Seinfeld）。有《宋飞传》……对，《宋飞传》。
Wings! You're thinking of Wings.
Wings was great.
I love Wings.
It's a big influence.
A single guy.
You're thinking a single guy.
A single guy, of course, the single guy.
That's what you're thinking of.
《展翅高飞》（Wings）！你想到的是《展翅高飞》。《展翅高飞》太棒了。我超喜欢《展翅高飞》。它影响很大。《单身男子》（The Single Guy）。你想的是《单身男子》。《单身男子》，当然，就是《单身男子》。那就是你想的。
Yeah, Carolina in the city.
But then there was that show with the gay guys.
Two guys in a...
Fraser.
On a pizza place.
That was ABC.
Frazier.
对，《都市女孩》（Carolina in the City）。但后来还有那个讲同性恋男生的节目。两个男人在……《欢乐一家亲》（Frasier）。在披萨店。《欢乐一家亲》。那是ABC的。《欢乐一家亲》（Frazier）。
Yeah, yeah.
And that's about it.
I guess that was that must-see TV stuff.
Yeah.
To wrap that up.
But you're like in this ideal position
of really kind of being your own boss
《欢乐一家亲》（Frasier）。对，对。差不多就这些了。我猜那就是“必看电视”（must-see TV）的内容吧。总结一下就是这样。但你现在处于这种理想的位置，真正成为了自己的老板，
and self-perpetuating.
And you've got this great sort of troop of collaborators and colleagues.
For sure.
Right?
Is it as ideal as it sounds?
It really, honestly, I really feel it right now.
It really is.
I feel incredibly, it's at a time when the business is tricky and things are going
并且在自我延续。而且你有一支很棒的合作者和同事团队。当然。对吧？真的有听起来那么理想吗？说实话，我真的能真切感受到。确实如此。我觉得极其……正值这个行业有些棘手、很多东西在
away and there's contraction.
And the fact that I'm currently getting to make a bunch of different things is, it
feels amazing.
And I'm writing right now, we're writing 100% here in L.A.
And it's me, Manzukas, Jason Manzukes, Sam Richardson, Vanessa Bayer.
And it's in the world of kind of like self-help influencer gurus.
So we're writing that.
We're going to shoot over the summer.
消亡、行业在萎缩的时期。事实上，我目前还能创作各种不同的项目，这感觉太棒了。而且我现在正在写作，我们目前百分之百在洛杉矶写作。演员有我和曼祖卡斯（Manzukas）、杰森·曼祖卡斯、萨姆·理查森、瓦妮萨·拜尔（Vanessa Bayer）。故事背景设定在那种自助心灵导师和网红的世界里。所以我们正在写这个。我们将在夏天开机。
And then I'm producing some other stuff animated and live action.
So it's great.
The strategy you were talking about Jason,
I have two kids.
I have a five-year-old and a two-and-a-half-year-old.
No way.
That's the stuff that starts to play into like how do we,
how do I do this and how do I be also home and around and involved so that,
然后我还在制作其他一些动画和真人秀项目。所以这很棒。你刚才说的那个策略，杰森，我有两个孩子。我有一个五岁的和一个两岁半的。不会吧。这就是那种开始影响到我们要怎么做、我要怎么做到既能兼顾工作又能在家陪伴和参与其中的因素，
so the opportunities, like, it's like how can I set myself up as well as I can
for opportunities that I get to have some modicum of control over, like where.
And be in line.
Los Angeles, too.
Yeah.
I mean.
Right.
That's, and that's what you guys know.
所以，这些机会，就像是我该如何尽可能好地为自己规划机会，让我能对诸如“在哪里”之类的事情拥有一定程度的控制权。并且在一条线上。也在洛杉矶。对。我的意思是。没错，这就是你们俩懂的。
Right now, they can travel with you, but as soon that five-year-old is going to be stuck in school
and you won't be able to pop around.
He doesn't want to be.
If it's any consolation, he doesn't want to be in school.
So we might.
Does he want to be homeschooled or he's just like, ah, I don't need.
He wants to kite surf.
He just wants to do, you know what that's fine.
现在他们还可以跟你到处旅行，但一旦那个五岁的孩子开始上学被拴在学校里，你就不能到处跑了。他才不想呢。如果这能算作一种安慰的话，他才不想上学呢。所以我们可能会。他想在家上学吗？还是他觉得：啊，我不需要。他想去玩风筝冲浪。他只想做，你知道的，那也挺好的。
That's awesome.
He likes to free solo.
He saw that free solo doc and he just wants to go climb.
That's hilarious.
That's very dangerous, Dick, for a child.
I know.
We got to let them,
太棒了。他喜欢徒手攀岩。他看了那个《徒手攀岩》（Free Solo）纪录片，就只想去爬山。太搞笑了。尼克，对小孩子来说这太危险了。我知道。我知道。我们得让他们去，
but we got to let,
it's lucrative.
You can first,
you can get that,
you and Jason knows,
you got to get to work.
Got to get these kids to work.
So, Nick,
但我们得让，这很赚钱。你可以先，你可以拿到，正如杰森所知，你得开始工作。得让这些小家伙去工作。所以，尼克，
so speaking about a kid,
you grew up conservative Jewish
and conservative Jewish kosher households,
so no,
dishes for,
separate dishes for meat and dairy stuff.
But I read that you had
one junk food day a year growing up.
说到孩子，你是在保守派犹太家庭和保守派犹太洁食家庭长大的，所以没有，没有混用餐具，肉类和奶制品的餐具是分开的。但我听说你从小到大一年只有一天垃圾食品日？
Oh, yeah.
And, and then,
what was the other thing I read about food
that you did?
Oh, that,
oh, that you fall asleep,
listening to a hypnotherapy tape telling you not to eat snacks?
哦，对。哦，对。然后，关于食物我还听说了什么来着？哦，就是，你睡觉时会听催眠磁带，告诉自己不要吃零食？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I went to a hypnotherapist to...
Did it work?
To quit smoking.
You guys all went to fucking Carrie Gainer at some point, right?
Did you ever go to Carrie Gainer to quit smoking?
Nobody can cure me.
I just...
对，对，对。我去看催眠治疗师是为了……管用吗？为了戒烟。你们肯定都去过凯瑞·盖纳（Carrie Gainer）那里，对吧？你有没有为了戒烟去找过凯瑞·盖纳？没人能治好我。我只会……
Iismander it.
Nobody can cure me.
She's my enemy.
I'm unstoppable.
There's nothing.
That will come between me and my darts.
I would love to see that Western,
a little spaghetti western of you versus a cigarette
我就是这样。没人能治好我。她是我的死敌。我势不可挡。没有任何东西。能阻挡我和我的香烟。我很想看那部西部片，你和一根香烟在对峙中的迷你意大利西部片。你们俩？不，我们是一伙的。我们不是对立的。所以晚上听那些磁带，这还是以前那种有人告诉我们，你可以通过在睡觉时
in a standoff.
Both of you?
No, we're on the same team.
We're not against each other.
So listening to those tapes at night,
was this back in the day when we were told
that you could learn languages
from just listening to the people speak to you
听别人说话来学习语言的年代吗？对，那是，嗯，我去找了凯瑞·盖纳，他就像是，你知道的，你会去他的，就像，你会去他在圣莫尼卡的车库，里面有一张被阳光晒褪色的卡梅隆·迪亚兹（Cameron Diaz）的照片。你会想：她当年也来过这里。我们希望如此。
when you sleep?
Yeah, it was, this was, well, I went to Carrie Gaynor
and he was like, you know, he was,
you'd go to his, like, you'd go to his garage in Santa Monica
and there's like a sun-fated picture of Catherine Heigel.
And you're like, she was here at some point.
And we think.
We hope
我们希望如此。
And
So I used him to quit smoking
And then I got this woman
From the Deepak Chopra Institute
And it was like this woman
She called me and I talked to her about snacks
And then she
Like my
然后我就找了迪帕克·乔普拉（Deepak Chopra）研究所的一个女人。然后就像是这个女人。她打电话给我，我和她聊了聊吃零食的事。然后她就像我的……
Because I just was, you know
Like we
It's got to go somewhere right
It's got to fucking go somewhere
So if you can't smoke cigarettes
Like give me some goddamn
Like you know
Sour Patch kids
因为我当时就是，你知道的，就像我们。总得找个发泄口对吧？总得他妈找个地方发泄。所以如果你不能抽烟……那就给我来点该死的，你知道的，酸甜软糖（Sour Patch Kids）。
Give me some fucking chip
Maybe some the same way.
She's just recommending snacks?
No, she would put...
So she would make the snacks, she would be like,
she would make the snacks,
she's like, what do you find disgusting?
And, again, using the Germans, a different version.
给我来点薯片，也许还有……她也是用这种方式吗？她只是在推荐零食？不，她会把……所以她会制作零食，她会问：你觉得什么东西最恶心？而且，再次借用德国人的梗，换个不同的版本。
I can turn that up like five different levels
and I got a couple different pitches.
Do you find poop videos disgusting?
People ask the questions?
You're like, I think I got the wrong number.
So, but she would equate
something like maggots are disgusting.
So imagine that you're, basically, imagine that your jelly bellies are maggots and they are going
我可以把那个恶心程度调高五个级别，我还有几个不同的推销点。你觉得排泄物视频恶心吗？人们会问这种问题？你会觉得：我好像打错电话了。所以，但她会将某种东西等同起来，比如蛆虫很恶心。所以想象一下，基本上，想象一下你的果冻豆（Jelly Bellies）就是蛆虫，它们会
to, you know, it's in my stand-up.
I do it.
I can't remember any jokes anymore.
But anyway, so I would listen to it when I'd go to bed and it works for a while.
But now, God damn, I want to eat chocolate pretzels all day in a little bit.
Of course.
Well, what if you just cut out the weed?
You know, if you cut out the weed, then you don't get snacky at night.
钻进，你知道的，这在我的单口喜剧里。我有讲这个。我已经记不住任何笑话了。不过不管怎样，我上床睡觉时会听这个，有一段时间确实管用。但现在，该死，我无时无刻都想吃巧克力蝴蝶饼。当然。好吧，如果你把大麻戒了呢？你知道的，如果你戒了大麻，晚上就不会想吃零食了。
Ooh, we cut out the wee, we cut out the wee.
You know what I mean?
I've got to be able to relate, my friends.
Last thing that I think is really fascinating that I did not know
is Harry Stiles helped you plan your proposal to your wife, Lily?
No way.
I'm a big Harry Stiles fan.
How did that happen?
哦，戒了大麻，戒了大麻。你知道我的意思吗？我得能产生共鸣啊，朋友们。我觉得真的很迷人、而我之前并不知道的最后一件事是，哈里·斯泰尔斯（Harry Styles）帮你策划了向你妻子莉莉（Lily）求婚？不会吧。我是哈里·斯泰尔斯的超级粉丝。这怎么发生的？
We were making that movie, Don't worry, darling,
which I think is most famous for the movie.
And...
It was the height of COVID.
Tell you what, that Olivia Wilde knows how to direct a film.
She sure does.
She's amazing.
Truly.
我们当时在拍那部电影《别担心，亲爱的》（Don't Worry Darling），我觉得这部电影最出名的地方就是这部电影本身。而且……那是新冠疫情最严重的时候。跟你说吧，那个奥利维亚·王尔德（Olivia Wilde）是真懂得怎么导演电影。她确实懂。她太棒了。真的。
She directed.
It was,
I had a,
and I played her husband in the movie,
and so it was really fun to act with her.
Like,
I mean, you guys,
it's like, sometimes when you act with somebody who's directing,
她执导的。那是一次，我在电影里演她的丈夫，所以和她一起演戏真的很有趣。我的意思是，你们懂的，有时候当你和正在导演的人一起演戏时
you know, it's different levels.
And she was great.
I mean, anyway,
so we,
so it was the height of COVID.
And I was proposed.
I was, you know, my wife, we were, and Harry sort of, like, we were planning it out.
We were at the, we were doing the, we had just done the table read, and we were all hanging out,
你知道的，有不同的层面。她太棒了。我是说，不管怎样，当时正是新冠疫情最严重的时候。我当时要求求婚。我当时，你知道，我妻子，我们，还有哈里，就像我们在策划一样。我们在，我们在做，我们刚做完剧本围读，我们大家都在一起闲逛，
and I was sort of figuring out, and we just, my wife and I just moved into our new house,
and so I, like, you know, I had a box, and I was like, can you just move this last box?
And she was like, can you just move this last box? And she was like, can you just move this last box? And she was like, I don't know, Harry.
So, no, she opened the box.
There's a bunch of flowers in the ring.
And then he checked in with me to be like, how to go.
So I told him basically before I spoke to like,
we spoke to our families to let them know that we were married
我当时在想，我们刚搬进新房子，所以我，你知道，我有一个箱子，我就说，你能把最后一个箱子搬一下吗？她当时就说，你能把最后一个箱子搬一下吗？她当时就说，我不知道，哈里。所以，不，她打开了箱子。里面有一束花和一枚戒指。然后他向我确认进展如何。所以我基本上是在我们跟家人通话让他们知道我们结婚之前告诉他的，
because he had been checking in.
That's so cool.
What a story.
Yeah, it's really, really cool.
Sweet boy.
Yeah.
Nick Kroll, you are a pleasure, a joy.
因为他一直在跟进。太酷了。太酷了。真是个好故事。对，真的很酷。好孩子。对，尼克·克罗尔，你真是让人愉快，太高兴了。
I can't believe how quickly this hour went.
It's bananas.
I know.
It's a real sprint.
I just want to say,
I've loved so many things that you've done.
The top three are...
No, no, the top...
我简直不敢相信这一小时过得这么快。太疯狂了。我知道。简直是一场冲刺。我只想说，我太喜欢你的很多作品了。前三名是……不，不，前三……
Well, I just watched Little Big Boy.
Yeah.
I watched Little Big Boy.
So fucking funny.
How far are you from Larchmont?
Is that where you're going to?
No.
And then, of course,
我刚刚看了《小大男孩》。对。我看了《小大男孩》。太他妈搞笑了。你离拉奇蒙特有多远？那是你要去的地方吗？不是。然后，当然，
oh, cavemen.
Of course.
I thought that was one of the funniest shows
I'd ever seen.
And it was six episodes.
I left based on the Geico character.
With Will and John.
Yeah, with Will and Josh.
哦，原始人。当然。我认为那是我看过的最搞笑的节目之一。一共六集。我是根据Geico的广告角色决定的。和威尔、约翰一起。对，和威尔还有乔希一起。
You guys had just done Blades of Glory.
Yes.
And then I was in four hours of prosthetics.
That was my first job.
I was in four hours of prosthetics every morning to be one of the cavemen.
It's so funny.
But I wasn't in the commercials and everyone hated the show.
They loved the commercials.
你们刚拍完《冰刀双人组》。对。然后我每天早晨要化四个小时的特效妆。那是我的第一份工作。为了演原始人之一，我每天早晨都要化四个小时的特效妆。太搞笑了。但我没演广告，而且大家都讨厌这个节目。他们喜欢广告。
Right.
Everyone was like...
I loved the show.
The critics hated the show, but what I always took solison was that the public hated it as well.
We got canceled.
We shot 13.
I was in four hours every morning.
It was my first job.
没错。每个人都……我喜欢这个节目。评论家讨厌这个节目，但我一直感到一丝安慰的是，公众也讨厌它。我们被取消了。我们拍了13集。我每天早上都要化四小时妆。那是我的第一份工作。
And it was the worst job.
And perfect first, you know what I mean?
Like, thank fucking God.
There's no way I could have done it later in my life.
So it's so funny that you like that show.
I love that show.
And then publicity, of course.
Yeah, you as Liz.
而且这是最糟糕的工作。完美的第一次，你知道我的意思吗？就像，谢天谢地。我绝不可能在后来的生活中做到这一点。所以你喜欢这个节目太搞笑了。我太喜欢这个节目了。然后当然是公关部门。对，你演的莉兹。
Hey, Jay, have you ever seen him play Liz from publicity?
No.
From the Crawl Show.
I'm going to send you a bunch of clips.
It's crying laughing about a lot.
Yeah, you've dealt with.
I mean, it's like, as a gay guy, it's like,
I would kill the playlist.
嘿，杰伊，你见过他扮演《公关部门》里的莉兹吗？没有。来自《克罗尔秀》。我要给你发一堆剪辑。笑得肚子疼。对，你处理过。我是说，作为同性恋，这就像，我会为了播放列表拼命。
I mean, yeah, great.
Thank you.
Well, we want more Nick Kroll.
Yeah, no kidding.
Everything and anything.
I'm stoked for your new show.
Say how much fun you had today as Liz.
我是说，对，太棒了。谢谢。谢谢。好吧，我们想要更多的尼克·克罗尔。对，没开玩笑。一切都想要。我为你的新节目感到兴奋。说你今天扮演莉兹玩得有多开心。
Oh, my God.
You guys, being on this podcast with you,
one of the most coveted slots
that any publicist could just secure a spot.
Spotify, top 20, Apple,
top 20.
the camaraderie, the friendship,
the absolute money grab that this
哦，天哪。你们俩，能上这个播客，这是任何公关人员都能争夺到的最令人垂涎的名额之一。Spotify前20，Apple前20。这种情谊，这种友谊，这个播客为涉及到的每个人带来的绝对的金钱掠夺，
podcast is for everybody involved.
It's an honor to be hold.
And to be held by you guys.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, Nick. Love you to death.
Thank you, Nick.
So good to see you, man.
Good to see you guys.
这是一种荣幸。被你们拥抱。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你，尼克。爱你至深。谢谢你，尼克。很高兴见到你，老兄。很高兴见到你们。
Thanks for having you.
Thank you, buddy.
Thanks for doing this.
You too.
Thanks, guys.
Bye, buddy.
Bye.
The funny.
谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你，老兄。谢谢你做这些。你也是。谢谢你们，伙计们。再见，老兄。再见。太搞笑了。
Funny, funny, Nick Crowle, yeah.
Yeah, it's so funny.
And I love that he showed up to play.
And he's so...
Always.
He's always ready to play.
Yeah, and look, clearly, he's got 80,000 things going on.
太搞笑。搞笑，搞笑的尼克·克罗尔，对。对，太搞笑了。我喜欢他总是全力以赴。而且他总是……随时准备大显身手。对，而且你看，显然他手头有八万件事在忙。
But how great are these interviews when they feel like five minutes and like you never,
you never get to your questions, you know, just because the conversation's so good.
That was so, that was so quick.
He's a good fellow, that guy.
I do send me some of that stuff, show you?
And then I'll bet I'll go, I'll go down like a usual.
Oh, do send me some of those things.
You'll send those bits.
但是这些采访感觉只有五分钟，而且你永远无法进行到你的问题，这不是很棒吗，你知道的，因为对话太棒了。那真是，太快了。那家伙是个好人。一定要发我一些那样的东西，好吗？然后我敢打赌我会像平时一样。哦，一定要发我一些那些东西。你会发那些片段的。
Right after my toilet.
Yeah, he's in full drag as Liz.
It's so funny.
I mean, the balls the guy has just to do anything.
Crosho, there were so many amazing sketches on that show.
Amazing sketches, yeah.
I should probably start.
But he did have, he said he did play that one character.
就在我上完厕所之后。对，他全套女装扮相扮演莉兹。太搞笑了。我是说，这家伙真有胆量什么都敢做。《克罗尔秀》里有那么多精彩的小品。精彩的小品，对。我可能该开始了。但他确实，他说过他确实演了那个角色。
Here it is.
Yeah, yeah, the teacher from a sit down, shut up, yeah.
What was the thing you remember about that teacher?
Fuck, here we go.
Are you ready?
Yeah, the character was, bye!
Bye.
Sexual.
就是这个。对，对，那个来自《坐下，闭嘴》的老师，对。你对那个老师有什么印象？操，开始了。准备好了吗？对，那个角色是，再见！再见。性感的。
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by
Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry
and Rob Armjarf.
Smartless.
Smartless。Smartless由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarf100%有机手工制作。Smartless。